in the flash I saw this grenade I'd see
it and it would disappear in the
darkness and then it hit my shoulder and
I remember like distinctly thinking
please let the grenade detonate below my
head it it detonated and it just felt
like someone took a big handful of rocks
and just like threw it at at my the back
of my legs and my my back Navy SEAL
training offers you this great chance to
kind of like reset who you are because
whoever you were before you became a
seal gets replaced with the person who
becomes a
seal
thank you so much for coming on the iced
coffee hour you got me through several
plane trips on the way here to Austin
yeah I've been downloading your videos
and just listening to them all the way
through they're incredible I mean your
ability to
storytellers that you pick are just like
it it it screws with my mind a little
bit it puts me in a trans like State
when I'm watching your videos time just
goes by like this and I'm not just
exaggerating like you are The Channel
that I binge told my mom about she
binges it tell my brother about he
binges it it's like you can't watch
three and not want to watch 10 more it's
crazy well thank you it's so funny like
there's lots of people ever since I
started making content that will say you
know I I binge your content I share it
with friends they binge it and there's
nothing that I'm doing that is designed
to do that it's just like the the
natural way that I comprehend stories
and tell them yeah like the way I told
stories in the first video is very
similar to how I tell stories now and
how I'm talking to you right now it is
literally how I speak but it's some
crazy skill now this is a a bit of a
tangent but in conversation with people
throughout your entire life were people
always just completely like enthralled
in it were they just like could you see
like a trans trans like State when
you're just talking to them must have
been good with this for a long time I
would say that I I've known that my
superpower of sorts is my ability to
tell a story I've known that for a while
um namely because I I used to I used to
run I I was a co-founder of a charity
that helped veterans get jobs jobs I'm
sure we'll dive into all sorts of stuff
but the short version is I periodically
would need to give you know Little Talks
at dinner to raise money and and just
like little public speaking engagements
and I was really nervous about doing
them but I discovered if I put whatever
I needed to say into story format
suddenly it was like my brain was just
it relaxed and I could very easily take
the stage and talk if I was telling a
story and so from the time I was like I
don't know mid 20s I knew that like if I
was ever going to do any public speaking
just turn it into a story and you'll be
fine uh and then just generally speaking
it's just the one thing I knew is that I
can I can retain huge amounts of
information if I can put the information
into a story in my head yeah so and and
for background my my father is an
incredible speaker he's a pullit
surprise winning journalist my my sister
is as well bunch of writers and speakers
and very talented people in my family so
I'm sure they kind of it rubbed off on
me speaking and storytelling what was
that like for you growing up did they
set really high expectations for you
yeah so I I grew up in uh just south of
Boston Massachusetts in a town called
quiny not to be confused with Quincy as
it looks if you're from the area it's
quiny Quin Qi NC y Quin quiny so yeah my
my family were they're they're very
educated very smart people like very
academically minded and so growing up
the you know success was doing well in
school and going to a good college and I
just like didn't want to do that cuz I
felt like I I didn't want do what my
family was doing like my my rebellion
was I'm going to do I'm going to do
something else I'm not going to be like
an academic but my rebellion was like
just being a bad student and like not
why did you want to rebel in the first
place I don't even know I to be honest
like from the time I was young I just I
I I think I think I have like a problem
with authority if I'm being C does this
guy so does guy yes you do don't act
like you always have a problem with
authority I think it's a good tra it's
taken you very far I think it's
something to be proud of I I for me yeah
I think that I I didn't like the idea of
Conformity and like you know in a way
like my my parents and my fames kind of
like pushed to be a good student and to
succeed in Academia like I didn't like
the idea that I was kind of being pushed
to do that even though it's a perfectly
sensible and very respectable path and
so I just naturally was like I don't
want to do that and so I my rebellion
was being a bad student so it didn't get
me much did part of you think like I
should listen to my parents or was just
like ah you know I know what's best for
me like dude I was I was so dumb like
just I I made so many bad decisions all
the way through like the time till I was
like 19 I like from from like the ages
of like 16 to 19 I just like blew up my
high school career just like how so like
what would you do well getting in
trouble you know like like out on the
streets with my buddies like stupid
stuff and like you know anything serious
or just nothing on my I do know you got
into a little bit of a scuffle right a
little bit of a scuffle yeah oh my God
yeah so like my my your first fight H so
my the my big first fight so I uh when I
was a sophomore in high school U well
actually you get the context is key so
in quiny uh street fighting is is a big
deal it's kind of like a right of
passage uh in quinsey it's not like no
one's beating each other up to the point
where you're like badly hurt it's it's
truly like scheduled like bar knuckle
boxing fights that that end with people
getting up and like shaking the hand of
their opponent type of thing um and so I
my group of friends in quiny were like
notoriously tough they were like the
guys that like won these street fights
and I was like I I didn't get in street
fights but I was around the guys that
did and so I kind of earned a I I was
given a reputation for being tough as
well even though I I really wasn't I was
like just a strap hanger like with the
other guys um and then at some point uh
in my sophomore year I was one of my
periods in school I was like in a study
hall with this girl named named Sarah
who was friends with my sister my older
sister and I just like sat with her like
talked to her during study hall uh but
it turns out her boyfriend took
exception to this he thought that I was
like hitting on his on his girlfriend
were there any flirty Vibes I don't no I
mean may maybe if you're like find her
attractive no she was just like my
sister's friend you know okay and and so
I found out through the grape vine that
Paul was really upset with me that's the
boyfriend and he's he challenged me to a
fight and you you must accept there it
is like you know you'll be outcasted if
you don't and so I'm like you couldn't
just apologize no there was no attempt
made there no apolog to like Smooth this
over I could have just been like bro
like I wasn't doing anything but instead
I was like time to defend my honor time
to live up to my like my reputation of
being a tough guy and so it was uh it
was right around Thanksgiving and the
scheduled fight with Paul was the day
before Thanksgiving and there's this
huge uh like the the girls from the so I
went to North quiny High School and then
there's quiny High School these are
rival high schools right big rivalry and
the girls from my high school would play
this flag football game against the
quiny high school girls but it like
quickly turned into like really
aggressive tackle football and it was a
whole spectacle but also at this like
illicit football game that's happening
that's totally unsanctioned there would
be all these like scheduled fights
between the two schools like it's a
whole thing it's a whole culture and
quinsey um and so my fight with Paul was
like the equivalent like the what's the
the to the main card for this
day Paul got it and so I uh this was
like weeks out too it was like two three
weeks uh before this fight and and I
remember I was like I in my basement in
my house I had like an office chair and
I'd like Spar the office chair like
getting ready for this big fight against
Paul uh and then the day come leading up
to this like in school like in North
quinsey High where I went like people
were very aware of this fight they were
like how do you schedule a day day in a
time with this person it's how
does how do you know weeks in advance
well yeah it's like I'm so mad at you in
three weeks we're going to fight by then
I just wouldn't care anymore i' be like
y you know I cooled down a little bit my
dad but so leading up to this this fight
in in the hallway like walking around
the high school like people would come
up to me be like hey man like you you'd
be cool to Paul man he's the captain of
the hockey team I don't want you to hurt
him cuz people thought I'm like this
really tough guy cuz the guys I'm around
and so I was like totally playing into
it I'm like
yeah I won't hurt
him I'll try to be nice to him like
acting all tough and then finally the
day comes and we go out to this field
where this this fight's going to happen
and remember like lots of people are at
this location for this girls football
game there's other fights that are
scheduled uh and so I get there and I
straight up have like a posi with me
like 50 plus people have like come to
support me these are like my guys and
I'm lit I could like see myself it's so
cringey I'm like standing in the field
like literally Shadow Boxing getting
ready for Paul to arrive and like I'm
there pretty early you know ahead of the
fight the scheduled fight time and the
the time you was supposed to be there
rolled around and he wasn't there and
I'm and and so I was like oh I guess
Paul's afraid of me that was my whole
narrative and I'm like telling other
people they like dude Paul's he's so
pathetic he's afraid of me again I'm
like Shadow Boxing still in the middle
of the field and everyone's like man
John's gonna kick this kid's ass if he
ever comes here and then Paul shows up
like 30 minutes late no posy I think he
had like one dude who like rolled up
with him and Paul walks up the hill and
I I see him coming to me and everyone's
like oh here we go here here comes the
fight and I have this line that I drop
he gets Clos to me and I'm like well
we're young motherucker as if it had
taken him so long like you're going to
make me wait and he comes up to me and
proceeds to beat the out of me what was
his first move what did he do he tackled
me the ground like meting a tackle no
I'm like stand up fighting and he he
beat the out of me in front of like not
only my school but the entire rival
school there was like hundreds of people
watching I like woke up and everyone's
like you got knocked the [__] out and
I'm like all right did you get a punch
in did you get anything nothing just
completely you were just a rag doll you
were his punching B that was it yeah he
showed up and just beat me up okay but
that the the things that that has to do
to your confidence I mean like didn't
help like I cannot imagine one thing
that would destroy my confidence and
just will in general more than just
getting beat up like that especially
after everyone's like hyping you up and
you're friends with all the tough guys
you know like it was break nose or lose
teeth or I looked horrible I didn't have
any like structural damage done to me
but it was like the classic like double
black eyy look like you got beat up kind
of thing uh but yeah honestly it was so
it was so absurd the way it happened
because really because of that line like
it would have been okay had I not said
the line not famous line but you weren't
expecting him to tackle you that's a
move that you can't that's true that's
true that's true uh but so I remember
like the after the fight like days after
I'm like in school and like literally my
teachers would say the line to be like
hey John While We're Young [__]
my actual teachers how they encourage
this it's it's a culture I'm telling you
it's a culture within quinsey is like
street fighting is is a thing and like
everybody knows about it but uh in a way
it was it was actually a good experience
it's funny now but it was good because
it's like one it shows you that you
can't parade around like a tough guy if
you're not or or you should have like
serious protection around you but also
like it it just put me in check I I I I
had come to believe that I was like
truly you know a street fighter I'm a
tough guy uh but I was not and it was it
it humbled me I think it was good for me
but then you compensated for that in
basically like the largest way possible
becoming a US Navy SEAL like that's not
just like you know what I mean guy gets
beat up at school oh yeah check this out
Paul Navy SEAL years of training what's
up now Paul while we're old mother you
could go in and just like would you
fight him today if he offered you a
rematch I mean probably not no I
wouldn't even be fair i' like trained
how to do it
now see him at the reunion just like
shoulder check we actually we talked
somewhat recently I I hadn't talked to
him since like the the fight you know
since I was like 17 years old but he
actually watches my YouTube channel it's
so like we've actually talked and he
thinks it's hysterical he he watched the
video that I posted on my channel that
talks about this thought it was
hysterical yeah so that's amazing so
what led you then after that fight to
then going in the Navy Seals I'm sure
there's a lot that happened in between
sure I think that there is some truth to
like that moment as kind of goofy as it
was you know and kind of funny as it was
it very likely did like spurn something
inside of me to like okay you got to do
something to like make up for this in a
way um but like you know for the rest of
high school I I really I really was just
like kind of not taking School seriously
I I really wasn't even pursuing College
as an option I actually only got into
college because my mother who was a
professional writer she wrote my college
essay and it was like it was so good
like the college contacted me to be like
you know you're not a traditional
student but my goodness that essay was
something else you're in so I got to go
I got to go to school how is she okay
with that she well she knew she's like
well John's not gonna do I had like I
had put off doing the application I was
like I was a terrible student with no
motivation you know and so she felt like
if I can if I can just get him in the
door do you remember what the essay was
about yeah it was about um so I had a
very close friend of mine who passed
away not to turn this into a dark
conversation but it was basically about
like my last interaction with him before
he ultimately overdosed and so it was
like a very poignant essay written by
somebody else about my experiences but
it was it was like a very powerful essay
that clearly spoke to the admissions
board and they let me it wow and then I
promptly in my first semester in college
I've been given this golden ticket John
here you go go to college
uh and I I think it was like I had 36
violations of just bad behavior nothing
significant all minor noise violations
like leaving trash in the hole like just
being a stupid kid in college that's not
taking anything seriously I had a at the
end of the first semester I had been
telling my family that I was getting
like all B's and A's going to the
library all the time doing so well
grades come out
1.016 GPA and they found out about my
GPA at the same time that the Dean got
alerted to how misb how badly behaved I
was because I I had apparently crossed a
threshold of a certain number of like
writeups in your dorm the 36 some
write-ups apparently you cross a
threshold and it goes to the dean and
they have to like review whether or not
you can stay in school and so I found
out that I had a 1.016 GPA and the dean
contacted my parents to be like your son
is very likely going to be kicked out of
Housing and there was also a riot at at
the school I was at that because our
football team that nobody cared about
lost the the big game that nobody cared
about but it was an opportunity for the
students to Riot about the game we
didn't care about and so there's this
huge Riot that t that takes place on
campus and I I really didn't do anything
in the riot but I didn't go in when all
the police are like running by shooting
rubber bullets at us they were shooting
rubber bullets you stop full right
that's a r okay cuz that's different gas
and stuff right it was oh yeah like
rubber bullets put it this way I got
shot so many times by rubber bullets
that there were rubber bullets in my
pockets just out of the like I got hit
everywhere but I got hit enough enough
time yeah what does it feel like it
hurts what what does that feel like uh I
was like a sting I don't even remember
it remember it's stung but you're like
you're so jacked up you're like this is
so much fun like running around from the
police so what was the riot like were
you guys like breaking windows and like
you know it was like what was it yeah
there was some window breaking for sure
but it was mostly like this map mass of
so there's so the school I went to is
UMass Amherst it's out in western Mass
and it's they call it zoomass slam Hurst
it's a complete party school and like
there's definitely an attitude within
the school uh there's like 30,000
undergrad students and nearly all of
them live at UMass so it's like this
huge population of students that are in
this part of Massachusetts that's like
very rural like this is It's like a city
it's like a city of these kids that are
like at a party school nice and there's
like a a a sort of culture amongst the
students to like just rage and be wild
like at all times and rioting has been a
thing at the school in the past it's not
like a new phenomenon like anytime like
the Red Sox would lose like a a big game
there'd be a riot at UMass Amherst like
that would make the news and and really
all it is is the students would pull
into the middle of this area called
Southwest it's there's these different
housing areas on Camp huge campus but
Southwest they have these towers these
26 story tall towers that the students
get packed into I was in one of these
and I think it's it's actually literally
the most densely populated area in the
entire country like per foot is UMass
Amherst Southwest area uh but these 26
story tall towers all closely clustered
together and then in the middle there's
like this paved Courtyard people just
wouldn't go to bed basically they just
stayed out like yelling and screaming
it's the middle of the night you know
and what started is like all right guys
time to go to bed like no one did and
then the the riot lights came on there's
like Riot lights set up on that sounds
like they're asking for it that sounds
like
into a riot the ri we're rioting right
now Jerry Springer the ding ding ding
and they just go to F the lights to come
on like but yeah the riot lights came on
and it like it riled up the crowd
completely uh and so there wasn't like
it there was really nothing other than
like we wouldn't disperse and so like
the school is accustomed to these riots
taking place where like lots of damage
has been done in the past and so they
were like full send like Riot police on
on you know horses like everything so
anyways uh I was just out for the bulk
of the time like I was one of the last
people like a shirt wrapped around my
head to fight off the tear gas that's
like clouded in the air uh and I'm like
oh cool went to bed like no big deal and
and then it turned out like the school
was super intense about figuring out who
was a part of this Riot and they have
cameras everywhere and they set up this
website the the UMass police where they
just posted all these pictures of just
random people who were out during the
riot and anyone could anonymously say
who was in the picture and they would
get like expelled and I was in all these
pictures and I've made so many enemies
at the school already just from being a
nuisance in my dorm that like I'm about
to have a meeting with the dean with my
father who's just found out I'm failing
completely at school I told him I was
getting good grades I also have to break
the news that I'm almost certainly going
to be expelled if I get named for one of
these pictures uh and I have like these
horrible grades so it's just a really
pathetic situation I had completely put
myself in remember I've also been gifted
the opportunity to go to college my
parents were paying for it my mom got me
in and so I remember my dad came up to
like go to this meeting with the dean
with me and he was like so mad he just
like didn't even talk to me and I was
like I've really [__] this up uh and
so I ended up withd drawing from the
school to avoid expulsion essentially
and because I was like not going to be
able to continue in housing and so I
went back home to quiny and I was living
in my mom's basement and it's so funny
like I look back at this moment and
initially I was like actually so annoyed
with my parents I'm like why'd you make
me leave school I I could have stayed
maybe I wouldn't have gotten expelled
you know like my friends are there that
kind of thing but then it like dawned on
me like no you're 19 and like you've
done this you're a joke and you're in
your mom's basement with no options now
uh and I think that was probably the
first time that I like recognized that
like okay I got to take accountability
for my life and I I want to like not be
this totally mediocre person who
certainly had the aptitude and and you
know the you know whatever to to be
successful in something like I don't
want to blow all that and so I decided I
would start by just like going to school
locally and like get good grades and so
I I didn't get great grades but I was
like getting be's at this local school
in Boston and it was like satisfying to
get my life back on track to a degree
I'm like going to I was I was working at
a gym I was like biking at 5:00 a.m. to
the local YMCA to work at a gym and then
I'd like go take classes at this local
school and so I was like kind of doing
the things to like get my life back
together um but I didn't know what I
wanted to do with my life and it was
around this kind of time for these like
couple of years I was living at home
that uh I began thinking about the
military mostly because a lot of my
buddies had had left high school I
graduated in '06 and a lot of them
joined the Marines and went immediately
overseas to the Middle East and like
there's a part of me that just felt like
a calling to go serve and so I began
thinking about it and it was around this
time that my mom uh she was like hey you
should talk to her best friends too two
brothers I knew they were in the
military and my mom was like you should
talk to them they were both Navy Seals
and I'm like what like we family friends
yeah that's not like a common thing like
when someone says they're in the
military you you don't like and so they
were retiring and so I'm not going to
give their names but they were like very
very big deal Navy Seals that served on
you know SEAL Team Six like the most big
big time like big time what is SEAL Team
Six I was never on Team Six which is an
important distinction for the people
that understand how the teams work I was
on what's called a whide team so all
Navy Seals go through there's Navy boot
camp there's a prep school there's like
effectively seal boot camp which is
another six months there's all this
Advanced Training it takes about two
years and then you become a seal but
you're a whide Navy SEAL and after you
do one or sometimes two rotations so
work up and deployment uh you can have
an opportunity to basically go through a
whole new screening process uh to
potentially go to Team Six and again
I've never done it but from the people
that I have very close friends that have
gone over there that are there now that
are there now it is like Navy SEAL boot
camp times infinity because now you're
you're literally competing against other
Navy Seals who likely have combat
experience who know what they're doing
and on Team Six it's a bigger deal than
even I think most people even fully
understand like when America needs to do
stuff those the people you ask to do it
and you can't [__] it up you are like
100% successful otherwise you're not
allowed to be on that team they took out
Osama correct oh yeah that was Team Six
yeah basically the the highest profile
the highest stake stuff goes to that
team and so the the screening process is
otherworldly like if you are not
basically perfect you don't get to be a
part of the team and so those dudes are
like superheroes is that something that
they have to dedicate their life too
like I'd imagine having a family and
like trying to raise kids it would be
almost impossible going through that
sort of training with that just being on
call I'd imagine 247 yeah uh I mean
again I since I I've not done it myself
this is very secondary but from what I
understand uh they literally have like
you know beepers or something and
they're on they're on call effectively I
don't know if it's literally beepers but
that is the idea I mean when there are
operations that kick off that are super
duper serious a lot of times they're not
necessarily known until very last minute
and so these these operators are like
constantly needing to be ready to
execute insane stuff how many people are
on that I actually don't know uh it's a
very small number it's probably if I'm
in a ballpark it's probably less than
100 you know they're actually operators
that's a complete madeup guess I'm
probably wrong but it's not much more
I'm probably off but it's it's a small
number of people and if you think about
it like I think that in total at any
given time I want to say there's like
either 2,000 or like 2500 active duty
Navy Seals across all teams that
includes the wh side teams so I mean
it's a small number of people not many I
thought it would be way more yeah I mean
it's a small community I mean every year
the out in Coronado California where
they do the initial training to become a
seal they run five classes a year unless
that's changed and even though each
class will graduate something like 50
people um which virtually all of them
will go on to become seals a lot of them
are actually from other classes that
they got rolled out of for injury for
failing something and so it's not like
those 50 people started with their class
and finished it's like over the course
of the year you have all these people
that get hurt along the way that keep
getting rolled or pushed around and so
like the true number of like new
recruits that get through is is
relatively small each year it's like
couple hundred people each year that
that get through it and when you meet
Navy Seals is there a certain like even
if you haven't met them in person like a
certain like eye contact or a bond that
you immediately have now I'm not
comparing this to something that I've
done but I did run cross country in high
school okay and when people tell was on
the bowling league that's true that's
true people tell me they've ran cross
country I'm like okay so you've pushed
yourself to a limit not like the limit
cuz you guys are like the limit but a
certain limit where you're like okay
you're you're you're dying on in a run
and then you push yourself even further
you know like I feel like there's a
certain like Brotherhood there but
obviously nothing not even 1% of what
you experience I'm guessing with other I
think that actually you're you're really
not that far off I understand that like
there's this even I just did it talking
about Team Six like you're constantly
trying to make sure nobody thinks you're
trying to misconstrue things here yeah
um but I think ultimately all it is like
when you become a Navy SEAL really what
you've done what you've demonstrated is
you're able to do what you just
described like hit barriers mental
physical whatever and then keep going
and really I do believe that virtually
anyone can do that but few people will
do that and so what you're describing is
really the same phenomenon that like if
you have if you're someone that has
pushed yourself Beyond a certain
boundary and you you see somebody else
that you know in virtue of being a
CrossCountry runner at a fairly high
level they've done the same thing
there's going to be a kinship there
there's going to be a connection um but
definitely with Navy SEAL specifically I
mean it's actually funny I I'll go to
airports and I'll literally spot one
like cuz their seals are kind of all
over the place they're traveling a bunch
and I remember I was like at the airport
in Atlanta and I like spotted a dude
from like that's so crowded super
crowded terminal and like across the
heads of all these people it was a quick
glance never met this guy in my life but
I knew immediately he was a Navy SE I
don't even know but there's definitely
like a it's got to be a posture or body
language definitely something there
there's also did you talk to him oh yeah
it's funny I walked up to him and it
wasn't like are you it was like hey dude
what team are you on he's like well I'm
on this team like cool man good to see
you there's no way I swear to God did he
know who you were just he could tell
that I also was a seal not that he there
certain perception there's something
that's like trained I feel like in the
back of your brain while you're going
through the academy where you're like so
perceptive of being in like public
settings I'm I'm guessing also this
translates to like okay like is this a
good guy bad guy like what's going on
like you know you're walking through a
grocery store and you're constantly like
looking around and is that a thing that
that you have hypervigilance yes you
have this oh yes so as you walked into
this house by the way shout out to Caleb
Hammer this is his house thank you for
letting Studio Caleb were you like
looking around and like being hyper
observant of all of like everything in
the house I mean I'm not going to say I
walked in and like literally identified
every exit but I definitely took the
time to like poke my head around the
corner and look around is that is that a
trained thing or have you always been
somewhat like that I definitely was not
always like that that that's definitely
more not not even trained it's more like
yeah I guess I guess trained is the word
then because definitely in training your
instructor to be super attentive to
detail in fact that would be if I were
to try to like sum up what your
instructors through Navy SEAL training
really try to emphasize it's this whole
it's not hey push yourself beyond your
Borders or whatever it's attention to
detail in all things like it doesn't
matter how tired you are doesn't matter
how complicated how stressed you are you
must must pay attention to details like
you must and even the slightest
infraction will get you kicked out of
training not literally every time but
that's the stakes they're playing what
is training like it's described as the
best time you never want to have again
uh because in many ways uh when I look
back at the uh the six-month long course
you so it's you go to boot camp this is
the this the pipeline for the enlisted
side anyway so not to get complicated
but the bulk of people who become Navy
Seals they enlist so they they're not
commissioned officers they're like the
sled dogs they're the the workers of of
the team uh you got to go through boot
camp which is just typical Navy boot
camp that's 2 months long it's in
Chicago um I don't know if it's changed
but when when I went through there was a
a mandatory preparatory school that you
go to immediately after boot camp where
for two more months you stay in Chicago
and you train with like literally
professional athletes and coaches and
Olympic athletes who have been brought
in by the Navy to not like beat you up
but to like actually build up your
strength build up your confidence
because that you're your next next phase
is actual like Navy SEAL boot camp um so
you wrap up your two two months in in
the prep school and then they send you
to Coronado California which is it's so
funny it's like the most be have you
ever been to Coronado California it's
like the most stunningly beautiful place
ever and like in this like iconic like
idyllic place there's like the most
treacherous military training like ever
taking place and it's very public you
can like watch it but you go out there
and then you go through a few weeks of
like what's called indoctrination which
is a few weeks of like you're not
technically in uh the training yet but
loads of people quit because you're
actually working with Navy SEAL
instructors and it's very intense you
know you're being treated really like
what's intense about it well one you're
you're there you're at like the story
compound where like by the way where you
train in cornado is also where the West
Coast SEAL Teams are and so you're like
this pathetic like have done nothing and
you wear you wear a white shirt with
your name stencl on it that like
signifies you're you're a recruit you're
nothing and when you go to training it's
like you're literally surrounded by
actual like active duty Navy Seals that
they just Haze you and it's like so it's
an intense place to be what's The Hazing
like it's it's mostly just like you know
goofing around with you like they'll
grab you and like make you come over and
like give a speech to like the like
they'll literally hey come over here
talk to these guys and it's like 10
active duty Navy Seals and like hey
introduce yourself and like you start
talking and they start like cutting you
off and making fun of you it's like
stupid stuff but so it's an intense
place to be and then I mean just
the the actual training is is in
incredibly difficult um physically you
know it's like the it's famously it's
famously challenging that's the whole
point they want it to be borderline
impossible to do so that if you are able
to complete the training you've
demonstrated that you can kind of push
Beyond you know what most people would
consider an impossible limit um so
anyways you do six months in in Coronado
it's called basic underwater demolition
SL seal school or buds for short
um and uh if you get through that you're
virtually guaranteed to become a seal
like the attrition rate Falls to near
zero at that point but you have another
six months of Advanced Training and then
you go on to um like we went to language
school no way no I can't I can that's
the line I say I was just about to say
I'm like you know can only way go no so
but you you go to like a follow on
school and then you uh you go to your
team and then you go through a whole
work again so but in terms of like the
actual training um sleep deprivation is
horrible it's so bad what does that feel
like I mean you lose your mind like
really you actually become an insane
person that's that's the gist there's
there's one week of training early on in
actual buds so so the six months are
broken up into three phases the first
phase is called first phase and it's the
gut check uh it's a lot of soft sand
running and laying in the ocean when
it's freezing cold at night and doing
like a billion sit-ups and jumping jacks
um you carry around this thing called an
IBS it's an inflatable inflatable boat
but it weighs like 200 200 someone
pounds and you and your boat crew uh
have to carry it on your head and it's
not that heavy it isn't like you put it
on your head and you're like wow that's
that's so heavy but you run everywhere
with this boat either by your side or on
your head think about this running on
Sand it's uneven and the boat's jostling
around and it hits the top of your head
so often that you actually develop a
bald spot in your head um guys like will
break bones just from compression of
this boat on their head like if you fall
when you're in the middle of a run this
boat just comes colliding down on you
it's gnarly like it's a it's a gnarly
thing so yeah but I'd say that the worst
part is sleep deprivation U and then
there's a week early on in first phase
called hell week where you don't sleep
for five and well you sleep for a total
of like four hours broken up into little
naps over the span of like five and a
half days oh my gosh um yeah so anyways
it's just it's a it's a very physically
grueling I am so curious like are how
well are they compensated afterwards as
a seal cuz going through that training I
mean to be like the top
.1% I'd imagine it's like it's got to be
like a high pay or do people do it just
because they they love it if you look at
like the entirety of like the enlisted
ranks in the Navy so all jobs Navy Seals
CBS you know whatever
um you are the most well compensated for
sure but you're not well compensated you
you can look it up I think guys make uh
like
50,000 gross maybe 60,000 when they get
to a team which amongst like typical
enlisted folks that go into a if if you
show up to your your first command as
like an an E2 or an E3 it's it's like an
enlisted rank the junior enlisted rank
you're making like I don't even know
it's probably 20 or $30,000 a year um
and you have you obviously get like
health benefits and all that stuff
but within the confines of what the Navy
is actually able to give you they pay
seals let's say the best but it's not
like you're not making a lot of money
you're not you're not at all um but then
when you deploy uh they pay you a whole
bunch of money but that's not really and
and that's relative it's not a ton of
money but for the military it's a good
amount you'll make like an extra I don't
even know I mean a couple 100 bucks
Grand shout out to my my manager Nick
whts who's off screen he's a combat vet
as well ni um yeah so you you get paid
for deployments and so if you deploy a
bunch you get more money but yeah it's
not it's definitely not something you
would do for pay um I think that you
know I I think that a lot of people
ultimately decide to be
seals uh because of the challenge of of
becoming a seal it's you know it's I
tell people that when I ultimately made
the decision to want to be a seal you
know it was it was shortly after I my
mom had said hey why don't you meet why
don't you go meet up with our family
friends here the the Navy Seals and I
met with them uh it's a funny story
actually how I met with them uh I went
to this place in New Hampshire where we
were going to meet um and my mom's best
friend uh whose brothers these were she
has this camp in New Hampshire that's
for kids it's like an art camp and it's
beautiful there's like little cabins
there's like a little Lake and it's so
it's this nice little area uh and just
up the road there's this gravel access
road that uh it leads up to this like
ramshackle like plywood Hut that's like
not in any way like permited it's a
crappy like Hut uh and when I was told
to meet with these two guys they were
doing like training
uh out of this Hut so this is like the
secret like Backwoods training center
for like tier one operators and so I
like go to this camp and I go say hi to
Susan my mom's friend at like the camp
the kids are all running around like
having their barbecues and coloring and
then I walk up the road like by myself
uh to this to this Shack and it's shut I
can hear inside like the sound of like
you know intense alpha males like having
some conversation like and I just like
open the door and walk it's all these
dudes that are like covered in tattoos
like super jacked all sitting on like
upturned buckets and it's like it's just
like dirt on the ground there's like no
furniture anything and they're just like
in a circle bullshitting with each other
and I walk in and they immediately go
silent and all of them just turn and
they're like who the [__] are you I like
I'm John I'm the I'm here to meet you
guys but it was incredible getting to
all Navy Seals and these like active
dudes who were like in between their
rotation Cycles what was impressed upon
me from all of them is this notion that
Navy SEAL training offers you this great
chance to kind of like reset Who You Are
because whoever you were before you
became a seal gets replaced with the
person who becomes a seal no one's going
to be like oh there's John like you know
the guy who flunked out of college it's
going to be there's John the guy who
became a Navy SEAL and I loved this idea
of you know SEAL training is such a
meritocracy it's it's actually open to
lots of people as long as you're an
American citizen and you're in decent
enough health I mean there's there's
more to it than that but a lot just
about anybody just about anybody can go
try out and that's whoever is at the end
is is an Navy SEAL and and I Lov the
idea of not only serving because I
wanted to serve but I love the idea that
the challenge and then the kind of great
reset that would happen if I became a
seal all my stupidity with college and
and just kind of being a general like
flunky would be replaced with something
that was honorable and I could be proud
of and I also fundamentally believed
that if I could get through the training
itself that I would literally evolve and
well not literally evolve but become the
best version of myself and I do think
many ways that was true and so you know
Mission success do you think there's a
personality trait that's that gravitates
towards that more than others and what
do you think that is I it's not so much
a personality trait as it's lots of
people that show up to training have the
same story roughly that I did yeah I
kind of screwed around didn't really do
anything out of high school you know
screwed up College got kicked out didn't
have a job you know no one in my family
has a history of being in the military
just seemed cool decided I'd go try out
like that's like the bulk of people who
make it through are that and I will say
that there's loads of people that go to
Seal training that are like super
intimidating people like when I was in
my class there was a dude who I had like
played with in Madden like he was a
professional football player I'm like D
I played with you like on a video game
that's like huge hulking like linebacker
or there's like professional swimmers
and professional rugby players and like
really incredibly accomplished people
but they wash out really really quickly
and I I think and it's something that a
lot of people agree with that the folks
that come in that are like I've done
nothing with my life and this is what I
want to do I'm going to reinvent myself
they got nothing to lose because they've
never done anything they if they don't
make it through training no one's going
to be surprised they're going to say
yeah John's a ding-dong he didn't get
through training that's not surprising
but if you're the professional swimmer
the professional rugby the professional
football player people expect you to
become an AB seal and as soon as it gets
hard the instructors Focus really
intensely on the dudes that are really
successful before coming in and they
remind them that this doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what you did before it
only matters what you're doing now and
it's like a lot of people can't handle
that and and also the people that have
been massively successful before
becoming seals they're not used to
failing I'm generalizing but a lot of
people like to become a professional
baseball player pretty good chance when
you were younger you were way better
than everybody else and it wasn't even
close and then in high school was the
same and then in college you were
probably one of the best people on your
team I mean even the people that get
drafted last in like the MLB draft are
incredible baseball players that were
way better than everybody else and so
imagine if your whole life you've been
the guy you're always the best at what
you did and then you get to training and
you're like you [__] suck you are
pathetic and you're not going to make it
through the training the guys that have
nothing to lose are like well that's
probably true I do suck I'll just keep
on going though but the guys that are
used to success they they do not handle
it well like consistently drop out
really quickly that is an interesting
archetype in the seals and I bet you
that that hit you very hard when you had
to move Mo back into the basement
because I see this theme of your life of
like not taking responsibility being
slightly entitled and just given things
you were given the role of like hey I'm
the tough guy you come up to me I'll
beat you up like you were given that you
didn't have to earn it you didn't have
to fight people you were given admission
into a good college you didn't have to
earn it your mom just wrote it for you
and you go to college and you're like
you have this entitled kind of thing and
then all of a sudden you get sent back
home that must have been incredibly hard
for you to flipflop as much as you did
yeah I mean I think that there's an
element of uh the entitlement you talked
about um I I also definitely came to
learn that taking accountability for the
things that you've done wrong is
actually a very empowering thing because
suddenly nobody gives you any crap about
it when you're just like fully owning
your missteps it allows you to just kind
of move forward unencumbered versus
trying to hide whatever missteps you I
like that I've noticed that as a theme
as well in your video like you'll bring
up certain things like getting beat up
by the dude the fact that you didn't
have to earn getting admitted into
college like you're very upfront like
yeah just kind of happen it's a way to
be just being direct so here's kind of a
novel question let's hear it how do you
feel when people come up to you oh thank
you for your service is it like a
genuine like oh thank you very much and
you might have to give a diplomatic
answer to this I don't know or is it
like a like a h you know I appreciate it
but it's kind of like you know I hear
that all the time you don't know what I
went through like what is the the
response to this well one I I I think
that I and virtually anybody else who
served would likely say the same thing
I'm sure Nick over there off camera
would say the same thing that like we
understand that when people come up to
us and say thank you for your service
what they're really doing is just that
that's the phrase that we've come up
with but it's just meant to be like I
hey I'm I respect that you volunteered
to do that you know and like I'm not
really supposed to actually be like
you're welcome you know and so I I I I
think you know I there's not a good
response to it but I definitely
appreciate that people you know
recognize that you know I I Rose my hand
when I didn't have to but I also don't
take it so seriously that I'm like and
I'm a hero you better respect me it's
more like yeah than appreciate it thank
you my honor you know what was
deployment like well they've only
deployed twice and I say that because in
the Special Operations Community like
there are folks that deploy like an
ungodly number of times to places that
are just the worst places in the world
so just it's important that people
understand that my experience with
deployments is as minimal as it gets
within the seal Community I I did the
minimum Tour of Duty um but I had you
know I'm not going to get too into
detail about what I did but you know the
the two places I went was Afghanistan
for the first deployment in 2013 2014 uh
and then I went to South America in my
second deployment in 1516 the one thing
I will say about Afghanistan is uh well
there's context so when you become an AV
SE or really when you become any sort of
uh person in the military that is a
designated combat role or you have
designated combat capabilities because
not everybody does there are plenty of
roles in the military that are
administrative or they're legal or or
whatever but if you've been trained to
like go to war it isn't that you pray
for war it's that you you you hope for
an opportunity to actually put your
skills to the test that that sounds
barbaric but it's a very natural thing
think about it you've been trained
extensively to do this you want an
opportunity to do it when we were given
the opportunity cuz it's a it's a weird
thing with how deployments happen it's
not you don't necessarily know where
you're going to go and then it kind of
ends up being like which platoon of
seals is doing the best they get the
better deployment which again would be
war and so our platoon was I think that
I think that we actually were the second
best platoon so we were not up for
getting to go to Afghanistan but there
was some issue with their chief on the
other side so we got the opportunity to
go I was so excited about going to
Afghanistan for the reasons I said to
you not out of blood lust but out of
like I'm a professional Navy SEAL I want
to go do my job but man it was
terrifying you know coming into it
because we knew and I can't get into too
much what we did not cuz I'm so cool but
just for sensitivity purposes we knew
where we were going was a what they
would call a Connect IC site like there
was the opportunity for actual combat
cuz there were people that deploy to the
Middle East where they don't necessarily
get into any sort of combat um but where
we were going it was kind of like a
known thing that you will see combat
that will happen and I remember we were
in this uh we wereing doing some
training in Nevada leading up to our
deployment and we had just found out
that we were going to get to go to
Afghanistan and this is like maybe a
couple of months out from deployment and
one of our more senior guys his name I'm
not going to say his name one of more
senior guys who had done several
deployments all to Afghanistan and Iraq
he was like you could see that he was
kind of crestfallen like you I remember
looking over at him and he's like a big
intimidating guy he was like a leader in
the platoon and it just looked like he
was really disappointed to hear we were
going to Afghanistan uh and so I walked
up to him afterwards and I was like why
aren't you excited about this I'm a
brand new guy I'm like wired to go do
these things uh and he's like because
someone's gonna die that's what happens
you go to these places someone here
right now is gonna get killed at least
one like every time that's what happens
and he was in no way like a coward he
was just he's done this before and I
think that was the first time that it
dawned on me that like to that point my
whole like journey to be a seal was very
Charmed I mean like it's pretty
incredible to say I'm going to be a Navy
SEAL and then go through all the
training and become a Navy SEAL there
are few moments as [__] unreal as
having a Navy SEAL stamp your Trident
into your chest because you've earned
the right to be called a Navy SEAL it's
like it's unbelievable
but it was like now I'm seeing the
reality of the job like I haven't gone
and seen it yet but I'm I'm seeing
someone that's done this before and
they're like I'm not excited about this
I'd rather go somewhere else I'll do my
job but that's the reality um I will say
fortunately our platoon did not lose
anyone on our deployment there were
several people hurt actually including
me that set the tone for me going into
the deployment I I started to look at it
more not uh scared but more realistic
yeah and um I remember before I actually
deployed my my family was definitely on
on the fence you know like worried about
it you know and I found myself going out
of my way to reassure them that it was
going to be fine like dude I'm I'm a
trained Navy SEAL I'm surrounded by Navy
Seals I'll be fine what it did is it
didn't really allow me to be honest
before I deployed about how I was
feeling because I was constantly putting
on this act of like everything's going
to be fine but internally I'm kind of
like freaking out a little bit about
what we're going to do and I remember I
was one of the first people in my
platoon that actually got sent to
Afghanistan they they they send you out
in waves they don't want to send you on
the same flight at the same time for
security purposes and I arrived in
Afghanistan um with like two other
people on my team so there's like
literally two or three of us I think and
the way it works is you do like a
turnover with the team that's you know
on site and there's a lot to explain but
basically imagine like out in the middle
of nowhere there's like these Hesco
barriers set up it's not even a real
base it's like a it's called an
outstation where you're you're on the
Leading Edge you're you're basically
near the enemy so to speak uh and we got
out there and first of all just the
drive from where we landed at this huge
military base which was like 45 minutes
away just driving to the out station was
like surreal because first of all
there's like we weren't allowed to slow
down because of the IED threat so like
once you get going you can't stop which
is hectic when you think about what that
implies it doesn't matter what's ahead
of you you have to keep going um and
you're driving through these bizaar in
in Afghanistan that are like full of
people from Afghanistan naturally who
hate you and they're looking at the cars
as they're passing by and they're not
scared of you that's the other thing
that you have been in that country for
so long nobody's scared they're just
staring you down and you're in this like
very up armored vehicle and it's very
cramped you got all your your kit on and
we get to the out station finally and it
was like such a relief to be behind
these Hesco barriers and we met the team
we were turning over with and they had
been there for 6 months these are like
seasoned guys they're they're getting
ready to go home and all they wanted to
do was get these turnover operations out
of the way as quickly as possible
because they you have to do a certain
number of just like patrols together
like show them the area and then they
get to go home and they're like we want
to get out of here and so we're going to
do an operation tonight and I'm like
I've never deployed in my life I'm like
so sketched about everything I arrive at
this out station my Kit's not even set
up my my body armor and everything and
like literally that night I remember we
we went through this whole mission
briefing of like what we're going to do
and it included like being on foot like
wandering in this area where like they
were like just make sure you carry a
knife because it can get hairy out there
and it's like okay and I remember after
our mission briefing of what we're going
to do which was really just a patrol but
in a very contested area I went back to
my it's called a chew it's like it looks
like a a the trailer on a tractor
trailer truck and it has like an AC unit
in it it's really it's it's it's kind of
an awful place to live but either way I
went inside there and I had all my gear
on cuz we're getting ready to step out
out for this operation in like an hour
and I got down on my knees and prayed
that we would not go on this operation I
was certain I was going to die you know
what I mean like not because the threat
was so high but because okay now I'm
really going to go do the thing I've
been thinking about and training for and
it's no longer like a game it's like the
real thing um and as as it happened we
didn't go on the operation that night it
got cancelled but we did go out the next
day and uh on many operations nothing
happens like doesn't matter how
contested the area is you get there and
nothing happens um but I would say that
over the course of the 6 months or 5
months that I was there uh we did get
into things that very much fit the job
description of what Navy Seals do and it
was a mixture of both exactly what I
thought it would be from just from a
training perspective you do so much
training that when you actually are in
you know a situation where you're using
your training it's just muscle memory
and everybody's so good you're looking
around at your teammates and it's like
it's it's gives me chills even thinking
about it like guys are fearless they're
doing all the right things guys that you
thought were like maybe a little slow on
the uptake of like how to do certain
things when when bullets are flying you
know they're pretty good at it and I
remember just being astounded at how
well- trained we were which was really
confident building but it was also like
like to say it was ADR adrenaline rush
is not even close the first time we like
got shot at I remember like being
immediately completely out of breath but
I hadn't moved like it was like my body
had tensed up so intensely that I
suddenly was completely gassed that's
another thing like in actual situations
you're like you can become winded really
quickly the thing that I always think
about is I've only done like the one
tour where we had you know a limited
number of actual engagements With the
Enemy and I think about these other
operators other seals that have been in
for like 20 some years through the bulk
of like the war on terror and I just I
can't imagine what it would be like to
have done back to back to back to back
deployments to these combat zones like
doing one was like life-changing and
terrifying and and all these different
things but yeah so it it was uh it was
intense it was really intense were you
afraid of dying at first but that
quickly Fades um people ask you know
what did it feel like to be living in a
place that you know you're kind of in
theory like facing your death
periodically um and I will say and this
is probably not unique to Navy Seals I
think it's more of like a military
deployment thing um you you you you're
not stressed you because you're in kind
of like survival mode you automatically
your brain just like filters out
everything else that could possibly
stress you out and it becomes just like
very simple you know it's like I have my
teammates who are like my friends I care
about them I need to eat I need to sleep
I need to like you know train but that's
it you there is no space in your your
mind it's like you the idea of stressing
about something from back home it's like
it doesn't compute when you're over
there you kind of enter this almost like
like Primal mind state where it's just
very simple and I remember I I have and
this is not like a I'm so cool but like
I've never slept better in my entire
life than I did after a couple of weeks
of being in Afghanistan not at first it
was very stressful but then you enter
into that kind of like okay like you got
just got to do your job and like support
the team and you're just like Carefree
it's very hard to come back to reality
though do you ever miss it sometimes
yeah not not not like miss anything to
do with like the military operation side
but definitely miss the the camarad and
being around my teammates because it's
like there there are few things that
that come close to what it feels like to
you know be risking life and limb with
other people in such a like really
intense and specific way um and so yeah
I'd say I miss the camaraderie but I
don't miss combat at any way what was
that like to be shot at or to get shot
uh well I never got shot I got shot at
um but uh you know I I I did get hurt on
that one deployment um a grenade Deton
next to next to me and the people I was
with um what hit you it did uh yeah I
went down this or not I I I was not a
team leader or anything I was just part
of a group and we were LED down this
Alleyway and it's the middle of the
night it was after of a day of a lot of
fighting back and forth um and we
basically arrived at this te
intersection uh in this fairly Urban
Village uh where we were anticipating
coming to this tea
like walking down here and coming to
this tea where there was this wall and
we were expecting to look out across
this field and and see potentially some
enemy combatants and we were just going
to see what they were doing but we ended
up walking down and we have night vision
on we're walking silently you know
maneuvering down this Alleyway and we
get to the wall and just stuff happens
the the intel was backwards they were
actually on the immediate other side of
the wall versus you know 100 200 yards
away and so we were kind of put into a
position where we ran the risk of being
heard if we turned around and tried to
leave U you your footsteps make noise
they hadn't heard us yet and so in short
it turned into a an Incredibly Close
Quarters contact and the the folks on
the other side of the wall uh we believe
they were holding grenades with pins out
like literally for this actual moment in
case we get compromised we're taking
them out with us and they lobbed the
grenades right over the wall right after
the shooting began and I remember um I
was like right behind somebody who was
engaging them and I watched like it was
in slow motion it wasn't but I will tell
you when you literally think you're
going to die it does you get like weird
like tunnel vision or something I
remember in the we had a a drone
overhead that was sending down an
infrared signal that was like flashing
so on night vision you could see this
it's like a spotlight imagine if God had
a flashlight shining it down on the
earth that's what it looks like it's
actually bizarre but only on night
vision you can see it and it was a
flashing strobe and it was like right
over us and I remember the flash was
like going like this but but in the
flash I saw this grenade like I'd see it
and it would disappear in the darkness
see it in the flash disappear in the
darkness as it's like coming over the
wall and then it hit my shoulder and I
remember like distinctly thinking please
let the grenade detonate below my head
so that it it'll kill me but it won't
blow my head off and that at least my
family will be able to identify me and
so this again this happened in like a
split second but it's like it hits my
shoulder and then it fell down towards
the ground and as it followed down my
body I'm like okay good maybe it'll hit
my legs and it'll just take my legs out
out uh hits the ground and I was able to
turn and everybody just kind of turned
and and it it detonated and it just felt
like someone took a big handful of rocks
and just like threw it at at my the back
of my legs and my my back um my sense of
what happened there is or my memory of
what happened is completely backwards it
took years to piece it all together but
the short version is I was basically
down on the ground bleeding to death um
we're also in the middle of like a very
intimate engagement with people on the
other side of this wall
uh and my medic uh who's also a seal uh
he was the only guy who was not directly
injured by the frag of the grenade he
was concussed he was not himself but
under Fire like from this close and it's
people Miss from this close when you're
that jacked up on adrenaline so you're
not like getting actively shot a million
times he like began dragging people out
uh he literally saved my life he pulled
me I I I was in and out of Consciousness
couldn't put my tourniquet on um you
know I was bleeding pretty bad for my
leg and he he dragged me to to cover as
much as we could and he literally laid
over me and put my tourniquet on and he
was like so calm you know he's like hey
it's going to be fine like literally R
trained for crazy yeah and so but the
crazy part was is it was kind of quiet
in the city at the time but once all the
shooting started the other fighters in
the town they just began like
arbitrarily firing like rockets roughly
in our Direction like they don't care if
they hit their own people they're just
trying to hit us and so like rockets are
coming in and like gun fires coming in
um and we actually uh we had to call no
I didn't I'm I'm down and out for the
count basically but the guy who's a jtac
they control uh overhead planes and
stuff calling them bombs they called in
an air strike like 10 ft away from us to
like take these guys out but it was like
how 10t away don't don't they explode
and couldn't you get 10 feet might be an
exaggeration it was on the other side of
that wall so the fragmentation was the
wall see through was it like a fence or
was concrete con no it was like a mud
bricks okay you know kind of like a
cement wall uh but yeah I I ended up uh
getting Medevac out along with another
guy who uh his lung collapsed from the
frag but we got medevacked out and I I
literally within like you know 48 Hours
had been pulled from the battlefield to
a field hospital and actually when I got
to the field hospital um this the first
stop we went after getting medically
evacuated a message had come out to the
base where this field hospital was it
was like 30 minutes away and there was a
bunch of seals that were stationed at at
this base and they didn't know
necessarily how badly injured like me or
the guy that was also getting metav how
badly injured we were and so there was
like a potential that in theory we could
be being brought to the hospital and we
could already be dead or we might be we
might die right and so out of like
respect all these seals in the middle of
the night put on their best uniforms
which nobody had nice uniforms overseas
they're ratty but like guys put on like
the equivalent of their dress uniforms
and walked into the tent and they were
lining the back of this like imagine
like literally what a movie would do
with like a a field hospital it's
literally a big tent with all these
surgeons with like white suits on gloves
on and then in the back behind all the
medical equipment was like 30 Navy Seals
in their uniforms which were all
mismatched you know cuz no one brings
those and I remember I got I got wheeled
in before I was put under for surgery
and it dawned on me that like I didn't
know the extent of my injuries I thought
that I was going to be okay cuz I'm like
I'm alive I got the tourniquet on uh but
I saw the looks on it's a very small
tent too I'm seeing the looks on my
teammates faces and they're in their
uniforms and I'm like oh my God like
this might be it I might die in here and
I remember trying to reassure them that
I wasn't going to die but I had no idea
I have no no idea what's going on and I
remember that they looked at my wounds
and they were like yeah you were very
close I guess the the way the shrapnel
went into my leg and my back was just
narrowly missed fatal um but anyways I I
I got shipped to uh Germany uh was there
there for a week and then I was home and
in Home Depot like two weeks later like
how do you assimilate back into society
after that that's what I I I can imagine
that nothing is the same it's like how
do you just go about daily life having
just experienced that well I I I
actually was talking about this with my
wife um I came back and believed very
much that I was going to do a I'd be
fine kind of
reassimilate um but I they call it being
in the red is the description used for
what it's like to come back from a
deployment um where it's kind of like
you're still in that almost Primal state
of living where like you've pushed aside
everything else in your life except for
you know fight live you know and and
just be on deployment and so you come
back home and it takes a little bit to
get away from that that feeling to
become less Primal to become civilized
again but you totally are not aware of
it even if you've been told hey you know
you just came back from a deployment you
need to calm down you don't think you
are you think you're perfectly fine but
you're so like wound up I'm sure you're
prob smiling about this you're he he did
a combat tour was it in Iraq yeah he's
he was a he was a okay so let give Nick
a shout out even though you can't see
him he he did a tour in Iraq where he
was one of the last people to do like
manned turret gunning now we use remote
control weapons on the top so he was
like fully exposed like driving in the
most contested and urban parts of Iraq
getting shot at anyways gnarly
deployment um we had remote controlled
guns in in up armored vehic icle that
was completely bombproof so if we got
shot at we were like completely safe but
uh I was just like really really mad
like there's a funny story within like a
couple of days of getting back to my
house in Virginia Beach I'm like
literally limping around I'm like I'm
like still hurt and I remember so we
lived in this house that was part of a
homeowners association like an HOA you
familiar with how I'm in one yeah so am
I of course of course you are of course
yeah do you know that works
dude and uh what's what's hway I'm kid
and uh I got back and my wife uh Amanda
she's like hey John just you know like
we got an email from the HOA saying that
our our Chimney Cap is Rusted and we
need to like replace it right and I'm
like no we not and I called the HOA and
I was like do you have any [__] clue
what I've just been through and you're
going to tell me I need to change my
Chimney Cap and they're like sir we
don't know who you are we don't know
what you've been doing you know what I
mean like what how would they know what
the I was doing it was like so like
unhinged that I believed that I could
just throw it in everybody's face that
like I served you're going to be nice to
me you know uh and they still made me
change the Chimney Cap um but uh yeah I
just was like hair trigger temper for a
while um but then you kind of like just
reassemble or you re you get back into
it but I would say candidly the the
injury uh totally changed my desire to
want to be in the military um I remember
we I I did I was able to heal up and get
into another platoon so do another work
up and deployment but I was like not
healthy I I I I so the the the blast of
the explosion um it dislocated both of
my shoulders and created a SLAP tear so
just like the shock of the the blast
wave it dis keep both my shoulders uh
but so it tore both of my my labs which
is like a it's a very fixable thing if
you get surgery for it but I didn't have
the time to do the full surgery and
Recovery I'd miss a rotation I wouldn't
be able to deploy again and so I got
what's called a biceps tendis which is
like the equivalent to putting a
Band-Aid on your your torn laum um but
it's like permanent they cut a portion
of your bicep they pull it out and they
staple it or something onto some part of
your B I don't even know how it works
but it's it's a permanent Band-Aid uh
which means you deal with like pain but
it's more functional uh so I had some
shoulder issues uh I still have 26
pieces of shrapnel in my hip and my
ankle that are like depending on the
weather it'll like you know it's hard to
run you know because of the pain from
the the shrap yeah um and so over the
course of the second deployment uh I
just like deteriorated physically
mentally emotionally um and I was
already thinking about getting out of
the military by the time we got back
from South America and I was already
talking to like my my medic and uh I
forget Corman that's like the the person
in the military who does medical and
they're like look you know you were able
to deploy a second time but you know
we're going to push for a medical
retirement based largely on the injury
from Afghanistan which clearly has had
Ripple effects physically emotionally
mentally I I was a [__] show I was just
like not a happy person and so I got
medically retired uh so I don't I don't
know how got an award you got a medal
right well yeah so you get you get an
award for getting hurt if you get a
purple heart which really just means you
got hurt uh it is an award and I'm not
there it's it's it's definitely one that
I'm you know proud to have I think that
technically to get the Purple Heart the
purple ribbon I think you literally have
to bleed in a in a war I think there's
like the stipulation is you literally
must bleed in a foreign war so it's like
kind of gnarly to have a purple heart so
that that was cool and you know it was
honestly the the whole experience now
was a was a good one I I feel very well
adjusted now but I've I've done
extensive therapy and still still go to
therapy to keep myself right was it
difficult to keep your relationship
together throughout all of that because
I'd imagine you deploying and coming
back it's like how could your partner
know what you went through and like
psychologically what you had to put
yourself through to be there and feeling
like everything in comparison is so dull
like I I would think everything is
Trivial after that yeah I mean my my
wife is the best uh shout out Amanda uh
she she and I got together in college I
actually so the to finish off the
college story I I actually did end up
going back to the college that I
withdrew from I did a couple semesters
locally in Boston got my grades up I met
the two seals and really found calling
I'm going to be a seal but I did finish
and I did graduate but I went back to
the first school UMass samher and I
finished out my degree there uh and when
I went back I met my wife Amanda and I
actually was telling her like I'm going
to be a seal that's what I want to do
and she's like okay and so like I she
was with me from like the Inception of
the idea through training deployment
everything um so she really understood
like I guess what she was getting
herself into as best as she could it's a
really really tight group of people like
the community of uh the other seals
you're with and the the wives and just
the partners like it's so so tight that
like when you deploy like the the
significant others all are like
constantly in contact and in many ways
they have information about what's going
on overseas because we're relaying it to
them so they're actually pretty well
kept up to date with what's going on
which I mean all the stuff we tell them
is okay they they know what's going on
but you're a different person after all
of that experience like you said it's
like a whole personal transformation
yeah I think you I think think that's
right I think that uh
I yeah I think you definitely do change
as a person and it's not Amanda was she
was on board for all of that yeah well I
think that she was I was a I was a very
like angry person for a while and I
didn't you know mostly just like I was
frustrated with everything that was kind
of my yeah yeah very much so but my wife
is just very understanding uh and always
has been she just understood that I was
going through some stuff and didn't
really give me a hard time and was just
kind I mean like I when I came back I
mean I I had some serious injuries on my
leg and my hip like gnarly stuff and my
wife took care of me she's like packing
my wounds like I remember I got I got
back to the to the states and they like
wheeled me in to like see my wife and I
I could walk at this point it was
painful I could walk and I get I get
wheeled in and I'm I'm in the most
compromising position ever I'm like on
my stomach and like my my butt cheek is
exposed because they've just been doing
all this like you know treatment for me
and my wife's like seeing me for the
first time she's and I have this
horrible like long hair like this shitty
beard and and she's like oh my God and
the doctor's like come on over here and
he's like packing this wound in my in my
butt cheek and it's like it's a
significant hole and he's like showing
her how to do it CU like you're going to
have to do this and she like nearly
faints and she's like watching this
happen but very dutifully like from that
point forward like multiple times a day
she was like taking care of my wounds
and like bathing me I mean she meet her
just in college just uh through friends
we just connected and I uh this it
sounds corny but like literally within
like 7 72 hours of meeting her I was
like 100% I'm going to marry her that is
incredible Okay so we've been talking
recently with a lot of different people
about different relationship advice and
a lot of them say you know off the rip
like if you don't know in the first like
3 weeks that this is someone that I mean
obviously granted there are exceptions
to that but a lot of the times you can
be right if you just know off the rib I
actually I remember telling my friend I
was walking across campus with him like
literally a couple of days after meeting
Anda and I was like this is going to
sound extreme but I'm pretty confident
I'm going to marry Amanda and he's like
what what are you doing dude I'm like I
don't know I just got a feeling about it
and she we got married like very quickly
I I got married before I went to to buds
she got married when she was a senior in
college how quickly did you get married
like we were together for like 10 months
or a year but we got married when she
was still in college and I'm like you
know 21 years old 22 years old and we're
still married got three kids now and I'm
35 so amazing that is crazy wow shout
out to Amanda yeah she's awesome super
she's like the opposite of me like super
introverted private like doesn't want to
be on any camera nothing uh but I every
story that you hear on the internet I've
run by Amanda like she yeah oh yeah
she's a huge part of it yeah so we do
want to get onto all the YouTube stuff
the True Crime stuff but first I have to
ask this question I was talking with
some some Navy pilots and they they
worked very intimately with the seals
they said that through training through
everything that it's not a matter of if
it's when you will break as somebody is
this true when you what do you mean by
Break by Break by let's say give up
information or just like like succumb to
something or like like if you're
captured do you mean yeah well I mean
you go through and and it's not just a a
seal thing it's like a did you go
through sear school didn't Washington so
sear school is is a school that the
military puts on for basically anybody
who could potentially be they were
telling us about it yeah Pilots for sure
cuz they get they eject an enemy
territory you're going to get captured
um and it stands for survival evasion
resistance and escape and it's a really
really like highly choreographed two
weeks of training at least the one that
I did but there's four levels of the
training you go through there's like
level one uh which is like you know it's
the most minimal amount of training and
then level four is like we're going to
simulate you getting captured and it's
going to feel real uh and they hire like
role players that are very aggressive
and are very good at playing the role of
cap and you go through like a miserable
it's hard so even from a seal you're
saying this after SEAL training you are
you are a Navy SEAL you have gone
through all the training and sear school
was the [__] worst it was the worst
it was like that is crazy to hear I you
know I I think that there's quite a bit
that is unfortunately confidential but I
I will say the couple things that I can
put out there are Imagine just like
being put in like highly uncomfortable
stress position positions that no one's
doing anything to you like you can't
quite stand up you can't quite sit you
can't quite lean over you know it's it's
a little bit too warm you know like that
kind of situation and then like you know
a loop of like scratching sounds or like
high-pitch sounds and then periodically
being dragged out and like
manhandle yeah really or like you know
we had to um like sit in a circle on the
hardwood floor which seems like nothing
oh just sit on the ground right but for
like 18 hours don't move like you can't
move for like you're just sitting like
cross-legged it gets so miserable so are
you now one to never complain about
anything because the guy sitting right
beside huge complainer you complainer
there we go the guy sitting next to me I
mean if it's like you know 69° in a
place he's like oh it's it's so
cold I'm like I'm like the you know the
memes that it's like I survived a tummy
ache making fun of men who like their
wife meanwhile is like giv birth like
the guys that got a tummy ache like I'm
the guy with a tummy ache I'm oh yeah
I'm like a Shameless that even but they
I don't know it's just probably who I am
and like I've been through stuff that's
like tough and everything but I still am
the person I am you know it's like oh
geez I don't want to do that that's
horrible so that's amazing but yeah to
your question though there's actually
like tactics that are employed that I'm
not going to get into uh that literally
are like a way of deflecting giving up
information that are remarkably silly
when you think about what you're doing
but they apparently because I've never
been caught or anything but they work
and actually one of the most profound
things about sear school at least when I
went through is they bring in someone
who has been a very real p and we had
this guy that was kept in the Hanoi
Hilton during the Vietnam war who spent
like a year in captivity gosh and and
they will emulate what they've been
through he just told us what he went
through and it was like everything he
said was like that's the worst thing
I've ever heard and then he'd be like
and then this happened and you're like
oh no that's the worst thing that's ever
happened like every torture technique
you can imagine but like this the guy's
like you know his spine's crooked like
from what happened to him but he's like
so positive he's like come on guys take
this training seriously you can do it
and we're all just like sitting there
like in awe of this person who's been
through like the most horrendous
experience so um it's a very very good
school uh in terms of like what it gives
you and it definitely arms you with I
think it would definitely at least
prolong until you give something up but
I think that maybe at some point as a
human being you might you might I don't
know this might be too much but I'm
curious why his spine was crooked or
what well he walked in and he looked
like a guy who had like gotten run over
by a train you know what I mean like he
didn't say hey my spine's crooked
because of what happened he walked in
and it was like obvious that he's like
unable to move correctly and he
immediately addressed it he's like a lot
of the things I deal with now are from
being held in captivity and he's like
literally crooked as he's standing there
and so we kind of put it together wow
yeah so he he was like yeah like all his
friends were killed and he was the last
one oh can I can I also ask how he was
able to survive captivity for I think he
was there till like like the the area
was liberated I think until Americans
came in tough dude yeah he like he like
lasted yeah wow yeah gnarly so that's a
jeez but yeah so I I luckily only had to
do the the training never did any of
that stuff in real life how do you make
the transition from all of that to then
starting the YouTube channel talking
about True Crime you know completely
random um I uh I've always been a big
Storyteller for sure just in my life
um and I uh when I got medically retired
from the the SEAL Teams it happened kind
of abruptly like we knew or I should say
I knew that I would be being I would get
medically retired I knew it was coming
but the date that I would be released
from service was not entirely clear and
then it was kind of like all of a sudden
I was told that actually your date to be
you know kicked out of service is like
right around the corner like super quick
and so I I I had this kind of frantic
like now what do I do like I you get
like a retirement uh you get paid if you
get mically retired it's like it's not
it's not really enough to live on but
it's definitely enough to like survive
for a little bit but I needed a job you
know I needed a civilian job I got
really no sense of what I could do I
mean as much as um you know people are
naturally inclined to think that Navy
Seals bring a lot to the table and they
definitely do beyond the battlefield you
know like just as people it's very
difficult to think about how you would
translate those skills and experiences
to like business especially when like
when you're in the military and it's not
just a seal thing it's a milary thing
you kind of live in a bubble you're
living in like the military bubble and
you're not really exposed too much to
like modern technology like as an
example I I get out of the the military
in 2017 and I didn't understand like
what a a Google sheet or Google doc was
and like I I'm I'm a I was a fairly
tech-savvy person before I went in the
military and I like didn't understand
like what what are this what are these
sheets these like Google Sheets that
people are sending me and like Google
documents I none of it made sense but
like there's all these like simple
things that you don't think would be
hard to learn but in the military you
have like your own software systems and
your own Hardware like all the
technology is like military you're not
touching civilian stuff and so you get
out and you're like not only do I have
no idea how to talk about what I did in
a way that's meaningful or that fits you
know the job description you're looking
for but I literally don't understand how
to use modern technology and so it was
it was this mess where I just kind of
knew that what I would need to do to get
a job and this is all leading to YouTube
Don't worry um
I knew I needed to like meet people and
so I was like oh Network you know meet
people through Linkedin or something um
and I wound up connecting with this guy
named Jordan celic who's this former
investment banker turned entrepreneur in
New York City uh and I don't even know
how we connected but it was this random
like he was looking to help veterans and
I'm like a veteran looking for a job and
he was this big proponent he believed in
networking as like a thing you should do
and I brought up I was like I want to
meet some people and he's like oh come
to New York I'll I'll I'll introduce you
to some you know know investment people
or whatever some Finance people and
whatever and maybe you get a job out
here and so it it quickly turned into
the there's a Snowball Effect where I
was like well you know can I bring some
of my buddies that are transitioning out
of the military as well and it quickly
over the course of like six weeks went
from I'm going to go to New York and
meet with Jordan and like meet a few
people to like you know 15 people on my
side all seals that are transitioning or
spec ops guys and like a whole bunch of
like hiring managers and folks from
different Industries in New York like
having almost like a conference um it it
like very uh spontaneous in a way but it
was this really cool thing where like I
remember looking out at this like sea of
like networking happening amongst elite
special operators and like these Elite
firms in New York and Jordan and I were
like this would be a really cool like
business like create a charity that like
hosts these types of events because
clearly there's a need for like veterans
to like learn how to assimilate and so
we ended up starting this charity called
Elite meet that we held these these
events where like Elite Spec Ops dudes
and gals met with business people and
they got jobs and it was great and so
ironically my job became running a job
search service if you will but we use
social media to to drive attention to
both get donations and to get other
hiring you know companies to come to
these events but there was this goofy
thing where you know Special Operations
soldiers Warriors whatever like they are
notoriously not willing to promote
themselves now I will say there's a huge
caveat there's tons of sealed content
there's lots of but like those represent
the minority of people that are like in
out of that Community the bulk of of
folks that are seals for examples will
like literally barely ever talk about it
they keep it to themselves it's like the
whole silent professional thing and it
almost goes against like a code of
ethics to even begin to talk about it
and so really there's a challenge
getting these guys to self-promote to
like get a job even when they're in the
even when they're in these networking
events that we're setting up and so I
began using social media to tell stories
about either specifically members of
these units I'd get the permission and I
would tell a kind of watered down
deployment story where there's some sort
of like you know takeaway that shows
that they're a great leader or something
but it was really hard to get permission
from people and it was just easier if I
talked about my own experience and then
relating it to how this applies to a
wide swath of other special operators
that like I'm the representation of the
Baseline and so if You' hire anybody you
know this this story showcases not just
what I can do what all these people can
do and I was really good at writing
these stories like they were like
LinkedIn you know like little like
several paragraphs long um and so that
was when I began thinking about like
social media just as a thing it was like
fascinating to me that just telling
stories written stories on LinkedIn
could drive donations like hundreds of
thousands of dollars in donations uh and
like very big businesses were coming to
these events these like little events
who are hosting from social media and so
I I ended up going off the deep end a
little bit with with social media where
um I ended up not so much posting about
how to how to drive attention to the
charity but more like how to build my
own personal brand as like a Navy SEAL
like a former Navy SEAL and I like broke
the the C the cart I committed a
cardinal sin uh in the sealed Community
which is like aggressive self-promotion
like above and beyond just trying to get
a job like I was posting stuff on social
media that in no way was sensitive
information it was nothing like but it's
more padding yourself on back like look
what I did and it's in the seals it's
about the team and and I'm also like I
did the minimum amount of time you can
do in the teams and I mentioned earlier
like there are people in the teams that
do like 20 deployments you know what I
mean I'm I'm I'm giving you my
experience from like two little
deployments there are people that have
done so much more and I'm on a wh side
team I'm not even on on Development
Group it just Team Six and so it quickly
I became like a piece of crap in the
eyes of the active duty seal Community
for the stuff I was putting online where
I was like you know I think I had like
50,000 followers on on Instagram all in
the strength of like talking about being
a seal I thought that I wasn't crossing
any lines but at the same time I knew
that it was like you know you're you're
making lots of enemies and I remember
when I started getting messages from
people that I served with like directly
like literally was laying behind a wall
taking incoming fire with this person
and they're sending me messages that are
not anonymous they're like [__] you
don't ever [__] say that [__] online
again you're disowned from the community
no yeah and so it was like heartbreaking
so you want to talk about like The
Humbling moment of when I got my ass
kicked in high school it was nothing
compared to like the barrage of hate
that I would get nearly every day what
didn't they like because I would see it
as an outsider and think this is in a
way inspirational for people who might
want to get into this a lot of people
would see your story and think this is a
career that I've never considered before
but I think I have what it takes I want
to be able to serve um to me it comes
off as something that that's more so
positive is like sharing these
experiences in such a way that that can
Inspire other people so objectively
that's all true and if you and I deleted
a lot virtually all of the stuff if you
were to go back and look at all of it I
would probably cringe reading it but you
would not read any of them and be like I
don't get it you wouldn't you wouldn't
read it and be like oh yeah I see that
because objectively all I'm doing is
sharing real experiences that are my own
I never acted like I specifically was
like the leader and I was the guy doing
this it was always really my actual POV
it was never meant to to prop me up as
being more than I was but it's almost
like if you start kind of pointing at
yourself and saying like I'm the guy the
SEAL Teams are just not cool with that
at all like you with with very rare
exception guys are get like all all
seals that are pretty public right now
are facing some level of of hate from
the actual active duty Community how
they handle it is it's on them for me
personally I became so depressed it was
so so I had I had to leave Virginia I
literally left Virginia Beach where I
was living which is a hot spot for seals
because I would go out and nobody nobody
acted inappropriate no one like but I'd
see people that I know I mean every
freaking Navy SEAL is like here in
Virginia Beach it's a small town and I'd
like get death stairs from people that
like personally knew me not like
Anonymous like staring me down like at
the gym or at the grocery store and it's
like dude I can't do this I can't be
here and so I like fled Virginia and
went to Pennsylvania to like literally
get away from people that hated me um
and then I made the decision you know
I'm like I I'm in a way building a
strong brand in the sense that I'm
growing my
followership uh on Instagram and across
social media but it's again it's all on
this like I'm the Navy seal narrative
and I remember talking to my wife and I
was like I can't [__] do this anymore
like I can't handle the level of hate
I'm getting like I mean really these are
deep cutting things from people that
really know you well uh and so I ended
up deleting everything but I was I was
thinking to myself that I still really
loved the like what social media
represented um I loved that that I Lov
the idea that anybody could post
something to the internet and in theory
they could like go viral and they could
become a thing I really I just love that
that was a thing it reminded me in a
sense of of like Navy SEAL training
where it's like you know anybody can try
out to a to a degree and it's whoever
makes it to the end gets it and so kind
of like a shot in the dark there's a
this this a condensed version but Tik
Tok was becoming a thing right around
the time that I was like okay I'm done
posting about seal stuff I'm giving it
up I'm going to get like a job at you
know Panera until I figure out what I'm
going to do um but I noticed that Tik
Tok was becoming a thing it's the
beginning of the pandemic and I was like
well there's probably not any seals on
there you know it's probably just like
kids doing dances and so I went on Tik
Tok and kind of like I remember I had on
my computer I had these documents these
Google documents I learned how to use by
this point nice uh and I had this one
sheet that had like all these ideas for
like types of content I could do and not
just for Tik Tok but for anything and it
was all like kind of rooted in the
military obviously or like you know
patriotism it was like all kind of stuff
that was in the world of military is
stuff and then I had this other document
that that had a single word on it that I
I I always wanted to cover this one but
I just I couldn't do it it was like so
random and off the- wall I was like what
are people going to think if I do that
one and it just said deat love deat love
standing for the very famous deat love
pass there's are you familiar with the
deat love P story okay well when I tell
you what I did with it I'll tell you the
story and so I remember I I've deleted
all my content the military content and
I just built this brand new Tik Tok
account and it wasn't literally my first
post it was actually after several very
cringey like I'm doing like all the
trends with the kids dude it so
bad like things are popping up dude I
was doing all that stuff and I'd like
watch it and be like this is is this
good no no no that's even worse we I was
just like an adult like doing these like
totally lame like kid stuff like the the
this one this one the worst one I the
worst one I did was the there was a
trend where it was like you do the the
autotune voice and you like kind half
sing a story in autotune it's so cringy
that I can't even replicate it now but I
was doing all this horrible stuff but
finally it was kind of like well you
know I tried Tik Tok it's not really
working and I remember I I opened my
computer and I I happened to have these
two Google Docs up the one of like my
exhausted list of like failed content
types and then the one that was just
like it Unsolved Mysteries and then my
one topic was diatlov and I was like you
know what whatever I'll just I'll tell
the diatlov past story um and so the
story goes and this is what I told in a
60-second burst on Tik Tok in the 1950s
there were these hikers these incredibly
talented hikers there's nine of them um
that were going to take what's called
their level three hiking test which
sounds like nothing but in the world of
hiking in Russia at the time these are
the guys these are like the professional
hikers okay these are the people that
can like scale Mount Everest and to get
your level three is like a really big
deal um at the time in the 1950s they
didn't have cell phones or anything so
to in order for them to take the test to
prove their level three they needed to
go through a fairly treacherous route up
into the Ural Mountains which are
covered in snow very icy and steep but
they didn't they can't talk to these
hikers while they're out there and so
they the the team that puts on the level
three test they they organize these
checkpoints throughout this this this
stretch in the eural mountains that are
spaced apart by like several miles and
it's just like random hikers and camps
and at at certain intervals they would
have to reach these checkpoints in order
to not only be accounted for but to
prove they're going the way they're
supposed to be going and so these nine
young super athletic super happy and
it's this is also very well documented
it was all filmed there's loads of
pictures they're haunting by the way
these nine hikers they take off and they
begin this journey into the Ural
Mountains and they they reached their
first checkpoint I believe and then they
reached this mountain pass and a lot of
this stuff is speculation but it's
believed they reached the foot of this
mountain and it's all everything's snow
there's no there's nothing it's like
this wide open snowy canvas and there's
this huge mountain that's covered in
snow and there's a storm coming and it
was late enough in the day where they
either had to Sprint basically to get up
and over the ridge to be safe on the
other side or they had to wait for the
next day for the storm to pass because
if they began going up this mountain
where they did need to go eventually and
the storm hit or it got too dark they'd
be completely like wide open there's no
trees there's nothing stopping them like
you never want to be on an open face of
a mountain in the middle of a storm and
so so they believe that the group
remember these are highly skilled hikers
these are like the best they decided to
make the journey up this mountain and
they stopped halfway they picked the
most exposed spot ever and so the
assumption is they they gambled they
gambled wrong they had nowhere to go and
so they pitched their Camp these little
crappy tents in the middle of this
mountain and they weathered the most
horrific snowstorm ever but at some
point in the middle of the snowstorm the
hikers were broken up into I think three
different tents
this is based on what they found they
cut their tents open from the inside and
they left like 75% of their clothes
folded neatly inside of their tents and
then they walked out of their tent in a
group almost in a line and they walked
down the mountain where there was this
this gaggle of trees it was I guess you
could call it a forest it was more like
crops of trees and we don't know what
they did down there but three of their
bodies were found up in the trees like
naked and like up on the tree and there
were all these scratch marks on the base
of the tree to indicate like they maybe
even tried to go up in this this tree to
hide from something that was trying to
attack them um then the footsteps
continued about a half mile like down
like parallel with the mountain to this
cave where they found the rest of the
the hikers and all of them were deceased
but the ones in the cave they had
exchanged clothing so like the men were
wearing the women's clothes women were
wearing the men's clothes uh and several
of them had pieces of their face they
they looked like they had been bitten
off like lips nose ears and some of them
were radioactive like their skin was
radioactive their clothes were
radioactive and so they're all dead and
so there's just no clue what happened to
them at the same time the Russian
military was doing an exercise in the
eural mountains and that night the one
of the senior people of of this military
command noticed overhead there were all
these strange lights which coincided
with where these hikers were like these
really in like think UFOs basically all
these lights over the mountain and he
actually called it in that he thought
there was potentially another military
unit like potentially an enemy like
operating in the Ural Mountains and it
was officially documented that there
were these unidentified objects floating
around the area where this all happened
and so when they found out that these
hikers were all found dead and there was
this sighting the Soviet government they
investigated and then their conclusion
was an unknown unnatural Force killed
them case closed and they didn't give
any more information about it it was
immediately swept under the rug and no
one was allowed to invest instigated it
was literally kept under like lock and
seal and then they they reinvestigated
it ironically like literally in 2020 and
they think that perhaps an ice uh shelf
had like broken off and killed some of
them and then like extreme hypothermia
could have led them to act a certain way
but like it doesn't explain the
radioactivity it doesn't explain the
lights in the sky it there's a lot of
things that go unanswered and so it ends
up being this like fascinating unsolved
mystery that's kind of stood the test of
time and I told that in a 60-second
version with the pictures included the
pictures of the tents are totally
bizarre it looks like they folded up
half their clothes and left them in
their tent cut it open then walked off
um but so I was at this uh indoor water
park in Pennsylvania with my kids and I
shot this little Tik Tok video with no
format I just kind of did a 60-second
version and since we're going to be in
the water park where it's wet naturally
I wasn't going to bring my phone so I
post this Tik Tok and I leave my phone
in my room and then I go with my kids my
wife down to the water park we having
fun and I back and my phone is like
practically broken it's got so many
notific notifications popping up on it
the video that I posted had like you
know 5 million views in like literally a
couple of hours uh and I everything i'
posted to that point had never gotten
even like a thousand or 2,000 views and
so it was like Mega virality and like
all of a sudden and it was like the I've
always been so fascinated with like
strange dark and mysterious tales and
like that story in particular always
interested me and so I was like oh my
God like this is the coolest thing ever
it has nothing to do with like being an
NA seal it's something that I'm really
interested in and I was like dude I'll
just I'll do more of these and so I I
like enacted this like really insane
schedule of I I I I posted three stories
like that one a day for 30 days which
was it sounds like nothing but putting
together in 60 second dude it's a beast
yes you know uh but I it GRE it grew my
Tik Talk account to like a million
followers in 30 days and I was at the
time I was very likely one the the very
few creators that was not doing just
kind of typical trendy stuff on Tik Tok
I was you could make the case that I was
one of the first big storytellers on
there and it just gave me like first
mover advantage in a big way like Tik
toks reaching out to me and like I got
my my partner and my manager and like
they're all like oh post more content
we'll promote it and like the account
just went huge it got to like seven or 8
million followers really quickly and
then I I was doing a live stream on Tik
Tok I was was doing that a bunch and I I
I guess I brandished a weapon that's
what they told me the algorithm said I
brandished a weapon I didn't I don't
know how that came up but it it gave me
like a 7-Day ban I couldn't it was the
first time from starting Tik Tok that I
couldn't post anything um and I decided
that I would shift to YouTube because
it's a monetized platform it's stable
and I've wanted to do longer form
content and so I moved to YouTube and I
posted a video that's actually my own
personal like ghost story I have exactly
one uh and it's it's barely edited I
literally sat in this room in my house
that has the worst Acoustics imaginable
it's this yellow awful back my my walls
are all like mustard yellow you can like
hear lawnmowers outside and I and it's
like unedited I'm just like sending the
story and it went massively viral on
YouTube and it wasn't because of Tik Tok
because I didn't there was no one going
over this was like YouTube algorithm you
posted something it went viral and I
think that that was probably the moment
and also based on comments a lot of
people were like who is this dude like
what is this and it that was probably
when I realized like okay the way that I
tell stories works for the for the
social media gods for the algorithm Gods
uh and that probably was when I was like
all right full send just just do this
now why do you think people have such
morbid Curiosities for some of the
stories because I listen to them and I
have to sometimes it screws with my mind
a little bit I I stop listening and I'm
like that kind of [__] with me a bit I
I I don't feel like more positive at
like I'm curious about I love it for
what but it's like True Crime stuff it's
like yeah I do struggle with it it's
funny um a lot of people that I speak to
that are fans of the show or the genre
talk about it being their like Comfort
show which seems totally backwards
because the content literally is like
99% somebody dies in some horrible way
like that's the gist of the content but
I think that as humans there is a there
is a desire to be frightened in a safe
control environment and what's more
terrifying than seeing real people that
had something kind of random and abrupt
that could happen to anyone happen to
them someone breaks into their house or
they like you they go to some off limits
part of a park and like they fall off a
cliff or something it's like it feels
like that could happen to me and I can
learn about it and kind of almost live
vicariously through this story but I'm
safe I'm like my my guide in this case
me is like telling me like buddy tuddy
telling you a story about this horrible
thing and you get you almost get like
the thrill of fear and anxiety but it's
not real it's this it's the same reason
we flock to like scary movies in movie
theaters it's because you want to be
scared but only because it's it's
actually not real but your brain
processes fear the same way but you're
in this controlled environment so you
get real fear real kind of shot of
adrenaline but the comfort of real
safety um but I do think it's kind of
like a human trait I don't think it's I
don't think that the the genre is like
been forced upon people I think that
humans have a morbid curiosity and I
don't think that's wrong I think it's
part of Being Human do you think that
seeing and experiencing obviously with
your your tour or your Navy SEAL stuff
and then also with like constantly being
subjected to all of this like very
morbid very kind of almost like gruesome
horrific stuff do you think that has any
effect on you in general sometimes it
does but it's pretty it's pretty I I I
think I stay pretty disconnected from
the material when I'm not like doing the
job of creating content and being Mr
Ballin like when I'm with my kids and my
wife like I'm I'm just John I'm dad it
doesn't feel like one world kind of
comes into the other however I would say
when I cover stories that have distinct
parallels to my own life and my own
loved ones it's really hard to to like I
barely ever cover uh content about kids
getting getting harmed because I just
can't do it it's too close to home for
me um I also you know periodically will
cover you know I covered the story about
this woman who um now I'm forgetting her
name unfortunately but she was this
wonderful woman in her 60s she went
hiking she's like a great hiker you know
did it all the time for exercise and she
got lost in this park broad daylight
like this is not some gnarly place like
in Pacific Northwest it's like Somewhere
In Like New Hampshire or something um
but she gets lost and being a season
tiger she decides to stay put because
she knows someone's going to come look
for her she's got a family that knows
she's out here she's going to wait it
out and so she just sets up her Camp
she's got food she's got water and she
just sits there but unfortunately no one
ever finds her and she say she stays
there for a month and she didn't know it
she was only like less than half a mile
from the trail um but she didn't know
she was that close and over the course
of her time in this tent where she
really never moved she she you know she
kept a journal of each day and she was
just So Graceful like dealing with what
was actually happening happening to her
she clearly recognized about 3 weeks
into her stay that she wasn't going to
be found and she now was too weak that
she couldn't she couldn't realistically
attempt an escape and so she knows she's
going to die but the way she wrote in
the journal was it was so profound it
was all of it was for her kids for her
husband the language was so like
positive and reminding them that she's
she's fine she's safe you know she's no
one's going to harm me I'm going to pass
away in my bed but it's like the grace
that she handled the ending with is just
it was incredible and she reminded me so
much of my mom my mom it was like it was
it was like telling a story about my mom
dying in this horribly tragic way uh and
that one just really messed me up it's
stuck with me for a long time and it's
not nearly the most gruesome story I've
told it's just it it it feels like I'm
seeing a bit of my life in the story and
those the stories that stick with you
the one that kind of messed me up was
the one actually it was like a mall and
the guy goes through this one door and
gets sent into this Corridor where it's
just like like a catacomb of just all
these different it's just like cement
walls cement floor cement ceiling and he
just sits down somewhere in this chair
and he never gets found yep that was the
one I still think about I'm like jeez I
know no that that yeah there was like
there's a mall in Australia that had
it's fam it's this huge huge mall and
they have like eight miles of like
imagine here's like the the outline of
the mall pretend it's a perfect
rectangle like bordering it but unseen
to the public are all these passageways
for staff and storekeepers to move
around away from like the main walking
areas you can like access store and
whatever from from anyways but there's 8
miles of it and it's really not
patrolled I suppose there's not much
there's not cameras there and this guy
was scile and he wandered into this area
and there were enough doors that were
locked around him that he just sat down
thinking okay someone's going to find me
but they didn't and it was just like
again just like so sad you know and then
when he was found he's like just hunched
over on his chair just sitting there for
like a month where do you find these
stories I mean honestly the the
beginning so I would say like call it
early 2020 to relatively recently like
within the we we we've professionalized
in in a huge way in everything now but
for the first like year and a half two
years I literally was just on on Google
you know trying to find interesting
things to look for um you know one of
the one of the the traps that people
fall into that cover content like that I
do is that there's loads of stuff that's
like on Reddit but it's personal
people's stories and technically it's
like a copyrighted thing cuz well it's
unverified one but it's you can get in
trouble for using somebody else's story
without permission this didn't
necessarily happen to me but it's Reddit
is is a place that people go and find
content uh but you really it's not a
it's not a successful way to find
content but a lot of people do it it's a
little little sketchy I I basically
wanted to find news I wanted to find
stories that you could basically you
would public news sources about them uh
and that it's a it's a chore doing that
like the easy way is you just go to
Reddit and you grab some crazy story
somebody told uh but early on I I really
wanted to make sure that I was not going
to get sued and so it just became
looking for really obscure news stories
I'm wondering how do you approach
something so delicately especially if
it's something that occurred
recently when maybe the victim's
families are still alive or the victim
is still alive but just you know out of
commissioner not not doing well like how
do you approach that in a way that
doesn't come off as like in you know
offensive or something like that I I
think that there's probably an element
of just literally the way I carry myself
and my demeanor and the way I speak is I
I guess it comes off as not
disrespectful to most people listening
and I don't think it's something I'm
necessarily attempting to do or like I
put it this way I'm not uh telling the
story I'm not putting on an act I'm
telling it the way that I would tell it
which is like with respect it's just
that's the way I would do it and I think
that it comes off very authentically
just based on feedback I've gotten that
it does seem like I'm being very
respectful of the fact that these are
real people involved um so I think it's
I guess innate that's just the way that
I tell the story it people think that
it's respectful um I also I do when when
we're writing these stories it's we
never we don't want to write a story
where my opinion is coming out even if
it's something that universally we could
agree is a bad thing like serial killers
are bad and they're bad people and
they've done bad things but I don't want
to tell a story where the focus is how
bad they are from my perspective I want
to tell you what happened with that
person and you can form whatever opinion
you want and so that is probably one way
that it comes off as more respectful
because it's if you if you if you watch
any video that we've put out or listen
to podcasts it's very difficult to find
an instance where you can tell how I
feel about a particular subject and
that's that's because the writing is
done to be very neutral and the story
carries the whatever opinion you want
you want to have um but then you
mentioned about how do we handle more
recent stories we do actually try to
stay away from stuff that's either
developing like that we don't have an
answer yet it's ongoing or it literally
just happened it's just it's it's tough
to sensationalize something that's
literally playing out live um and so
when we do that we we'll reach out to
the to the families to the victims like
especially now I mean not to like toot
our own horn but we're we're big enough
now where like if I post a story about
someone and it's ongoing like they're
going to hear about it and so it's
pretty routine to post a story and then
get feedback from family members and
people involved and publicity on such
events could also be beneficial to
solving them as well I feel like that
could help getting all these eyes on it
yeah I mean we we not not to some extent
not we've we've not done this a lot but
there's been some instances where we've
covered a story and intentionally drove
viewers to like a GoFundMe page you know
yeah we did one for this this guy who
was sky instructor oh my gosh that was a
sad story man he flipped himself around
and he took the fall and saved the
student who was strapped to his stomach
wow they they teach instructors this
move that you do if you cannot get your
shoot to open and you're doing a tandem
jump where you basically flip yourself
over and you take the fall to try to
save your student and he did that and he
totally saved his student but he's
paralyzed you know neck down um so he
got loads of publicity at the time it's
this heroic story but this guy has
massive medical problems for the rest of
his life and he's not that old and so I
we told the story but we preemptively
got in touch with him and we said we
want to cover it and we're going to push
people to your girl fundme page and I
forget what it's at now but he's
probably we raised like 400 plus yeah 4
unable that's the one Andrew cried
during really the one I was telling you
to listen to yeah I got to listen to it
it's a good one what does your team look
like today how many people are on it how
is it structured well it's very
important to understand the way the
business is structured because
one of the things that I'm not trying to
do is be like the boss because I'm not I
I I a I'm a really good speaker
Storyteller like on the creative side I
got that down but I am not really a good
manager I I've had experience managing
and leading and to a degree I'm decent
at it but it's something that I'm I'm
I'm not good at regular communication
with people I'm kind of like like uh
bipolar with people I'm like super cool
with you and then like I'll like I'll
see like one thing that I don't like
that you're doing and now it's like well
now I don't like you at all
anymore and and like unfortunately it's
like that's that's horrible like you
can't run you can't build a team that
way uh and so uh I knew that about
myself and so when I when the YouTube
channel was doing really really well
like early on I was starting to get like
you know requests to do sponsored
segments and and all that and I just
didn't really even know what to do I
just like kind of ignored everything um
and then I I uh I I got reached out to
by this company called called uh night
media they do all this talent management
fantastic yeah yeah yeah I had been
approached by a couple other people that
were in the talent management space to
like be my manager uh and it made sense
you know I need a manager to deal with
these sponsor segments and stuff and I
just I didn't want to work with anybody
because I'm like so worried about how
I'm going to handle like being around
these other people uh but Nick uh he hit
me up and he was like the only dude out
of all the people that reached out to me
that didn't really have a pitch
everybody else was like oh I can expand
your business this way and do this this
this this and he was like hey dude like
I was in the military too you know I
don't really know what you need you know
if you need help be happy to help you
like let me know and I was like that
dude seems cool and then I proceeded to
immediately blow him off completely when
he was he asked me to take a call with
him and I blew him off just I was like
busy but then I called him like cold
called him uh and I was like I was at
that point where and I'm maybe you can
relate to this I don't know but like I
knew that I was like the YouTube
business was a real business but it just
felt like I was running around with my
hair on fire like I'm like last second
getting uploads done like so stressed
like just working 24/7 but making you're
not really getting ahead you're just
like trying to keep the lights you're
just trying to keep things yeah and it
was like I could feel myself starting to
slip like I was missing uploads and I
was like really burnt out and I like
poured my heart out to Nick I'm like
dude I don't know you this is my first
interaction with you but you seem cool
but I'm like falling apart here dude and
I I have like trust issues with like
other people I've worked with I'm I'm
not good at like leading teams like I'm
not good at it I need someone who can
like really step in and and like do
everything else so that I can just do
storytelling and Nick's like all right
cool man and like true to his word like
the dude he's right over there you can't
see him he's a looks like a viking to
give you a visual I mean that's
atimidating right there yeah bodyguard
really yeah literally he's doubled as my
bodyguard several times um but yeah no
he uh Nick is so his background is he's
combat vet um he was a lawyer and he
also worked at WME talent talent
management so the best stars in the
world he came over to night media doing
digital uh talent management he was uh
one of the managers for Mr Beast and so
he'd like done like the highest level of
digital management uh and we just like
hit it off and I could just tell Nick
had all the skills that I didn't in
terms of building a business and so we
went from uh me an editor and a topic
finder who didn't even work out the
topic finder was Finding like zero
topics so really was me and an editor uh
to now we have 37 employees
no is that fulltime or is that like some
what we have 37 employees we have um my
gosh how many are in the United
States all but two all but all but two
my gosh what in the I had no idea I
would assume it's like you and like five
people Max well so there's there's so
there's there's there's a lot of facets
there's a lot of stuff just a lot of
moving so we have like on the only so
the only thing I do is I take scripts
that are written and then I work with
them to make them sound like me because
I have a very particular way I want to
sound and then I tell the story and the
way I tell stories is I like study the
story and like embody it and then I tell
it it's not a I'm not reciting a script
you know uh and so that takes up like a
lot of time and mental space and like
but that's what I do I go to my studio
and I record stories I don't do anything
else I I don't hire anybody I don't fire
anybody I don't sit on meetings I don't
I don't do anything I'm like a I'm an
employee of the company because like I
know my strength like I I know what I'm
really good at and I know what I'm not
and Nick came in and he has all the
skills to like build a business and he
has all the relationships and the drive
and so he we ended up leaving night
media to form our own studio so ball in
studios since August 2022 we formed
Ballin Studios and Nick just went he
hired and fired so many people and now
we have like it's like a worldclass team
of people it's it's I sat on the first
Friday meeting last Friday the first one
in a long time uh and like the the last
one I was on there was like five people
on it and now it's like there like 80
all these different blocks of Zoom
people and it's like all these like
brilliant people that are like doing
these incredible things within our
organization and it's like I noticed
you're posting everywhere like even your
Facebook has like almost 4 million
people on there yeah so I'm sure a lot
of that's like syndicating to all these
platforms and building these businesses
off of it
yeah I mean the thing the thing that it
has we're still working on but I think
we're pretty good at doing is everywhere
things get posted whether they're being
handled by a third party or they're
being handled by a team member or
whatever they have to feel like a
genuine like Mr Ballin post it can't
become like you know random crap that
nobody nobody thinks I'm posting it they
think somebody else is and so to do that
requires an enormous amount of training
like you you don't get to just come in
and oh hey write a script or oh oh like
do some resar search over here like no
there's a formula to it and like you
know the right now the the head of
production for us is actually my sister
who's she's she's a two-time Pulitzer
Prize winning Brainiac she's super smart
but she's developed like a course that
people go through just to learn how to
like begin to write you don't even
you're not even a writer yet you go
through three months of she's editing
you you like the
Seal of writing that is impressive so
she's editing you as well as uh my dad
who also is a pullit surprise winning
Journal and he's he was the head of the
spotlight team so like the movie
Spotlight where Michael Keaton's the
lead so Michael Keaton like worked with
my dad to like learn how to play him in
the movie oh my gosh and so we have
these like incredibly talented
professional writers and editors that
like put our writers through like the Mr
ball in boot camp and it's we've only
hired like a handful of writers after
the whole thing and they're so good and
the topic finders are so good what I
love about your style is it still seems
like I'm just talking to you you know
what I mean it seems like a Campfire
Story it's very intimate it's not like
all this crazy editing all the it's just
so real you know what I mean and I think
that it fits the theme so well so it's
very shocking I like I wouldn't say I'm
super shock because I I can see the
views I could see you know how big you
are on all these different platforms so
I assume it's a massive operation but it
is still like a little bit shocking it's
37 people and you know what the thing
about the 37 employees is that nobody
has and I'm not just saying this because
I'm on this podcast nobody has a job
that you're like why why are you doing
that or like why do we have someone do
that like those positions are gone like
you have an opportunity when you come in
to work with us to like we want people
to like come in as like an assistant and
then have blue sky as it's yeah Blue Sky
you can become a writer if you want you
can become an onscreen person for a new
show like no one's stopping you you got
to do the stuff you're responsible for
and there's intense training for it
that's all filtered through Nick yeah
but like everybody knows knows that like
we are expanding in every direction I
would love to see different offshoots of
just like different stories and
different segments I mean as it is we
you know we have uh Bedtime Stories the
the amazing YouTube channel that they
now are under the Ballin Studios
umbrella doing a podcast with us we just
launched that uh it's like top 20 across
the board I think at one point it was
top 10 it's kind of hanging around the
top 20 Mark uh we also uh I say we very
liberally Nick is the one doing all of
this I'm just staying in my studio
telling stories Nick understands Talent
management having been in it and so he
started a talent management business so
we have like nexo and we have Nick
Crowley who are being under they're
under our management wing and they're
loving it like they're we're helping
them hire writers we're going to
researchers everybody is actually
playing a pretty meaningful role and
there's like department head meetings
every Friday and like everybody better
come to the table with like what you're
doing because it's can be really obvious
if your Department's not doing anything
not that I would know cuz I'm not on
those meetings but Nick tells me and
that's what happens so you need to do
more podcasts I don't know know why you
haven't like CU I this is like my first
one I know I we I mean obviously we did
research but I couldn't find enough on
you to research nice like you're still
you know what I mean I think you as a
person to me is more captivating than
all the stories I mean the stories are
great but I think you as a person that
to me is what's most impressive is like
the background of who you are and I
think it makes the stories that much
more impactful just knowing like just
what makes you tick and your interests
and and the business side of things but
it's not only that but it's like
how you met your wife you knew it was
her and like that's also in and of
itself something that just doesn't
happen that's super rare what
relationship advice do you have for me
who's engaged and Jack who's single I'm
a bachelor he's to be you know I I
actually have something that I said to
myself that I still say now and it seems
simple but I I I always say to myself I
will always be good to Amanda and it's
just the simplest phrase but it applies
to everything like there's really very
rarely a fight that you get into that
can't be solved with just stepping back
and being like you know what I'm going
to take the high road and be good to my
partner like when I when we first got
married like I'm like 22 going through
the most stressful training and it was
like the only person I was around when I
wasn't training was like my wife and I
was like kind of a jerk you know half
the time because I'm just like so
stressed and I just like saw like if
that's the path you're going to go
you're not going to be married for very
long and so I I like literally adopted
this mindset of when in doubt like
always be good to Amanda and like even
now like I literally say it's myself if
we're arguing or upset about anything my
bottom line is like that's the person I
want to be with and so why would I like
soil it by like focusing on something
that's kind of asinine was there
something that she did in those first 72
hours where you're like okay like that's
that's it I saw a picture of her I I saw
so I I obviously saw her and I was like
hanging out with her but there was a
picture of her she went to South Africa
like for this like school trip or
whatever with the college like right
before we met and so all her friends
that went like went out and like partied
and had a great time but Amanda is like
this totally like motherly person and
she found these like little kids that
were in South Africa that were like
playing at the playground and all Amanda
wanted to do was like go like hang out
with these like little kids and like go
pet the animals that were like Strays on
the roads she's just like a very
wholesome person and there's this
picture of her where she's sitting on a
swing and she's holding this little girl
who clearly she doesn't know it's this
little kid that's like flocked to my
wife uh and she just like looks like the
perfect Mom I don't know I was like
that's like I want I want that person I
want like that soul to be around my kids
who's just like naturally loving and
caring and just like an old soul I
suppose and I still like look at that
picture all the time like CU that's when
I fell in love with my wife it's like I
saw that picture and I was like that's
the one how do you find someone like
that I don't know I don't know I think
it was just luck that I found her uh she
was just a a friend of a friend you know
yeah I don't know I think I got lucky
that I met the right person you know and
I think now like you know it's probably
really challenging to meet people or I
should say it's it's almost like uh with
the dating apps you can meet so many
people not I haven't used a dating app I
met her you know normally in college or
whatever but like you have so many
choices it probably makes it really hard
to like I'm going to stop now because
it's the Paradox of choice but the
problem is you do have to make your
decision at some point you know what I
mean so you can't just continue to go on
new dates meet new people forever that
that is something that I'm I feel lucky
to have just met somebody and it worked
out I think that's partially luck you
know I have a question feel free this if
you want to cut this let me know if you
don't think Amanda looks great in a
dress and she asks you yeah do you tell
her oh no no way dude she she's
beautiful no matter what you know
respect I respect that no she I I'm
obsessed with my wife like she would
look good to me no matter what she was
wearing I want to be at that level I
want to be at that level we always get
conflicting answers some people are like
absolutely honesty is 100% if she if if
she doesn't look good in that dress I'm
going to tell her and then she
appreciates it because when she does
look and I tell her she looks great she
knows I mean it yeah but then some
people they say it's not the suit that
makes the man it's the man that makes
the suit you know what I mean there you
go I I think that uh the one thing
that's been great about uh this career
path that I'm on now is in a way it's
well it's it's candidly it's very
isolating being I'm sure you can relate
to this Gram I'm sure you both can uh
like a as you become I guess more of a
public figure within the YouTuber space
it's you you don't really feel like
that's happening you feel like you're
just making videos and like it's cool
and it's like you're making a living off
of it and it's awesome people like know
who you are you like go out and they
like know who you are and it's like so
flattering it's like the coolest thing
but it also like it it's very isolating
because you're not really it's it's
harder to relate to people in a way uh
maybe I just react that way to it um but
I found that like because I met Amanda
way before I was Mr Ballin like she
knows me as John and it's like the
purest relationship you know it's just
just me and my wife and so as like the
whole Mr Ballin thing has grown and I've
definitely had some people aggressively
take advantage of me and like it's
there's been some rough stuff I've I've
always had Amanda to like be real with
me you know I can be completely
unfiltered and real with her and it's
helped our relationship tremendously
that like she's my number one and she
knows me for me I'm not Mr ballin I'm
not a nav seal I'm like the dude she met
in college and so it's strengthened our
relationship tenfold how often does she
shoot down ideas we like I think this is
great and she's like oh could you give
us an example does she have veto power
uh yeah so she she like so we're doing
uh our first live show in a week
actually a week from today um and all
the stories that I've selected for the
show have been run through Amanda and
like she told me like a few of them
she's like no don't do that one like
that's no one's going to like that one
like don't do that one I'm like all
right yeah I completely wanted to do
that one but because you said so I'm not
going to do that um but definitely story
selection she yeah if I if she doesn't
think it's good and she's Shameless
about being honest if the story is good
or not like she'll like literally be
like no that's boring like halfway
through the story so is it just you
internalize the story and recite it to
her as though you're filming and then
she tells you if it's yes or no it's
just the concept so no I I like
literally will be out in my studio like
researching it and like internalizing
the story and then before I'll film it
uh I'll say hey man let me just run the
story by you and I'll literally do like
the whole thing it's not that's the
coolest coolest thing I would love to be
a fly on the wall where you're just I
just tell her the story it's like in the
kitchen she just listens and then she
gives feedback it should be a side
channel of just you running the stories
by her and the stories that don't make
it on your main channel should be the
side Chann there are many I'm sure
they're good but they're just not like
top tier yeah she's she and she'll be
very honest that's that's the key she's
very honest with me how many of these
stories do you tell your kids zero
really do you let them watch the content
or no no when will you I don't know it's
a weird thing like it's funny like my
oldest uh she's eight actually oh my God
yeah she's turning eight soon
she um she's seven now anyways her
classmates have not not many of them
they're seven but there have been
classmates that when I pick her up they
recognize me and it shows there are
seven-year-olds that are watching this
content they recognize you yeah
seven-year-olds well I think that my
daughter very likely has tipped them off
but they par they think a superhero like
they they walk around with you daddy
goach you don't think so I don't think
so I cuz my kids like they're young
enough that they don't really understand
what I do Ella my oldest definitely
probably does she wants to be a YouTuber
and I think that's probably part you
know but like my youngest Henry who's
three like he knows like there's such a
thing as Mr Ballin but doesn't really
understand what that is and like my
middle same thing uh that is so funny
but yeah no they they don't watch any of
it in fact the live show they're going
to be there for it and it's the first
time they're going to hear any of this
stuff like they don't they don't even
know what they're walking so they just
think like dad's going to come and like
tell a story to basically and it's f so
at night every night I I tell my son a
story but it's like completely fictional
and it's so I lay down with him every
night and I say okay Henry What story do
you want to listen to and it's like a
T-Rex story and I'll tell the story of
like Henry and the T-Rex that's like
made up on the spot like so see just
make it all up making them all up on the
spot yeah I just like make story and I
tell my kids stories all the time but
they're like happy friendly stories
ponies and princesses and stuff I
couldn't do that I don't think I could
just make up a story on the spot like
that professionally tell St
all do little I know but but there's
there's difference in reciting something
that you've internalized versus like
making something up on the spot yeah
it's fictional yeah well I mean luckily
it's a three-year-old he's not going to
judge the story too hard inconsistency
he pointing that out so you you haven't
picked out a time where maybe you'll be
comfortable to share these stories with
your kids I don't know I mean you know
it's it's like there's the two parts of
my life that we've discussed at length
like the the Navy side and the YouTube
side they really don't know much about
it all uh mostly because I I probably am
over Sheltering them to some degree like
they know dad was in the military at one
point but like what does that mean um
they don't know what a Navy SEAL is they
don't know what war is you know uh and
similarly they don't really understand
that like the world is a scary place and
horrible things do happen and that's
what's covered on YouTube and I think
that like I'm probably resistant to the
idea of like I don't know showing them
the reality of of the world not that
like my YouTube videos are like that's
the world like that's the worst part of
the world that's not the world but yeah
I think I'm just I'm just a little
protective of my kids I do
wonder is it important for people to
know about the evil that exists in this
world like is it important to understand
that you can go out and something bad
can happen to you to contemplate your
own mortality to know you could be
driving and someone can just come and
hit you in the car and like like do you
think that it's important that people
don't live in some sort of state of
blissful ignorance but they're aware
that bad stuff happens yeah I mean I
mean I think that from a I don't know
vigilance standpoint I think it's
important to not be totally naive if
you're out in a public place you should
be aware of how to leave that place you
should be aware there are probably
people in the in the crowd that might
want to do you or your family harm I
mean that's that's that's life so I
think that like you you shouldn't be
like at all times thinking someone's
going to kill you but I think that the
reverse of that is is far worse if you
think that everything is sunshine and
rainbows you're wrong that's not the
world we live in no matter what you
think it is when you go and sit down at
a restaurant I've heard of this thing
where like you can't have your back
facing the door is that true or is that
a bit over like well I would say the
people that I know that have done
numerous like intense deployments uh are
much more likely to have that kind of a
I guess tick of some kind um I don't
think it's Universal I I I would say
that if I was given a choice I'd
probably opt to be able to see an exit
but I wouldn't be like oh I can't sit
here you know so it's probably not me me
but there are definitely people that act
that way I mean if you if you are on
edge because you've seen some stuff
that's like screwed you up whether
that's military or in your life I think
it's natural to see the exit and that
makes you feel comfortable why do you
think you did such a good job
assimilating back into society where a
lot of people go down the path of
alcohol drugs destructive behaviors sure
well I didn't I I I didn't do a good job
I I went to extensive therapy for a long
time and and and that literally saved my
life I mean I was I when I got out of
the military when I was medically
retired I was really struggling with
identity like with my now that I'm not a
seal what am I um and then I I TR I went
into the I'm going to be the token Navy
SEAL online and do all this content that
makes me look I'm getting all this hate
from like my literal what I thought were
my best friends that was that's deep
cutting stuff I was so depressed I was
miserable and depressed in like 2018 it
was like the lowest point of My Life um
borderline suicidal like that that was
how bad it got but fortunately um I
actually was I was I had these like
flashes of anger all the time like
completely like random like things that
shouldn't make you upset or making me
mad and it stood out enough to friends
and family they're like dude like you
got some issues you got to go see
somebody um and so I did I I I went and
saw therapist um outside of the military
and I will say I'm not Shilling for
anything right now but like therapy
works uh and it's not just something you
do when crisis hits it's something you
should be doing preventively uh and so
like I I would consider myself
incredibly well adjusted now but I
absolutely still speak to someone
because it's like that's part of your
health yeah you know so I I think I was
able to pull myself out because I had
friends family support I had a
professional
therapist I think that's the reason I
hope I'm not prying but how are those
relationships now with with the Navy
guys horrible still destroyed gone have
you ever tried to mend that or is there
no point at it respect I just
I think that now enough time has passed
since I was posting the stuff that
ultimately triggered the reaction I got
like it's been so long and and dude I
this is the first time I've spoken about
my military stuff publicly in like years
and this was frankly even watered down
um so I don't think that these people
necessarily are holding vendettas
against me I think a lot of them
probably forgot don't even care because
it didn't affect them personally it was
like oh screw that guy um but uh no I it
frankly it's it's a it's a troubling
part of my life that I have people that
at one time I would have literally died
for and who would have literally died
for me that I am I don't talk to at all
like people that meant an enormous
amount to me that are no longer in my
life and yes I'm sure I should probably
be the one to to reach out and do and
I've done that with a couple people but
it's painful to to even breach that I
think that I've just kind of a avoided
it and maybe one day you know our paths
will cross again but not holding my
breath so I've heard this theory that
you experience a range of emotion on a
scale of 0o to 10 and then you get
married and then the range of emotion
extends to10 to 20 and then you have
kids yeah and then there's no range it's
just negative Infinity to Infinity as
someone who's probably experienced a
very intense range of range of emotion
while going through the academy at
different stages of your life would you
agree with that statement that even that
range of emotion you were experiencing
in those Hard Times PED in comparison to
when you became married and when you had
kids I I would say having kids is the
one that does it for me uh the range of
emotions I felt were 0o to 10 and in all
in all the ways up until I had kids and
then you have kids and it's like I can't
believe people do this I can't believe
people have like children this is so
much work and it never stops and it's
there's this funny meme that it was like
like the highs and lows of parenting and
it was like the low's are you know your
kids destroy an international vacation
and they like you know they like break a
window at a restaur restaurant or they
like you know peel over the carpet but
the highs are like oh Johnny caught a
pop fly today it's like why do we do
this you know but it's it's it's it's so
rewarding having kids they you just you
it's funny at the end of the night my
kids all they go to bed and I always
like go into their rooms and like look
at them sleeping in their bed and I'm
like oh my God I love my kids so much
they're so wonderful I I do those are
all true sentiments but it's like then
the daytime rolls around and it's just
like chaos like everywhere and that
would be like there are days that are so
stressful that you're like how and so
parenting is a is a tough task and my my
wife does the bulk of it so I'm this is
me complaining this this is my
complaining side uh but yeah know having
kids is is a is a whirlwind to say the
least I respect your humility I would
say that's a a theme that I've seen
through this entire thing is your
vulnerability and your ability to
acknowledge the fact that like you
messed up yeah certain times in your
life and you messed up bad and uh I
respect that I think a lot of people
could could take note of that and learn
from that thank you yeah I I would say
that that's a conscious thing that I do
it's a conscious thing it's conscious in
the sense that I I think it's important
for me to be I I can get carried away
and and think I'm really great at stuff
and like become very egotistical but I
the way I I don't do that is just being
real with myself and taking
accountability for my missteps and not
being afraid to talk about them because
I think that it actually makes you a you
come off stronger and more competent
when you're willing to be honest about
your missteps and I think that like you
you picked up on it I'm not sitting here
trying to play The Humble card but it's
it's it it makes people respect you and
they want to engage with you they want
to be around you because like you're
being a human a lot of people hide the
things that actually are the most
they're the biggest parts of humanity
like being a screw-up you know and I
show mine to the world and I think that
that's the good way to do it so so you
mentioned the live storytelling event
that's kind of crazy you're doing now
are you are you nervous yeah
of audience yeah no I one of the
questions leading empath this I saw in
the email was like what what's your um
values and philosophies in life and I
actually I I had an answer planned I'll
tell you oh okay good because that's
something I meant to I meant to ask you
because you studied philosophy I did I
did I did but this is actually more just
like life experiences led me to have one
really specific thing so in addition to
in my marriage I have the Mantra of I'll
always be good to Amanda in my life and
the thing that I'm literally teaching my
kids is like you got to do stuff that
scares you because often times and this
is not something I coin but like the
best things in life are like on the
other side of fear as I think Will Smith
said actually in my life the things that
scared me the most that I actually went
and did like being a Navy SEAL there's
so many tests you got to take through
SEAL training they're horrifying they're
so scary but I did them and I I
accomplished those things and each time
you get through those scary test Gates
it like it your confidence grows like
your your your knowledge and experience
GRS and I I've just become someone that
like even if I even if I kind of don't
want to do it I'll like push myself to
do something that makes me so [__]
uncomfortable like for example in a week
I'm going to step on stage with a mic in
front of 1300 people 1300 people tell
stories that's a lot of people it's in
front of 1300 people it's sold out
Paramount Theater down Austin you sold
it out yeah it's a good idea is it just
you oh yeah I I literally I told Nick
and my team I said it's important for
the first show to be all on me I don't
want a highly produced show I want it to
be like give me a mic and a stage
obviously you know what stories you're
going to tell and you've rehearsed this
I'm sure how do you feel about that
terrified but that's why I'm doing it
like literally that's the reason I I am
scared to do a big public speaking event
so I'm doing a big public speaking event
but it's so it's it's impressive I'm
I'll I'll be psyched about it when it's
done right now I'm like what what the
[__] You' been through so much to me
this seems like this would be an easy
thing it's like oh
yeah story it'll be good and there there
is some truth to that I think that like
you know in my moments of insecurity
about this event because I've known
about this for months and months you
know I do remind myself that I have
literally done things that are life and
death at times I've gone through the
breach you know uh and I've also done
I've done public speaking not a lot of
it I've spoken like 50 people like a
couple times but you know I I think that
like a lot of stuff that scares us is is
actually not nearly as scary as it seems
and and I think that that's what I'm
almost addicted to is like I like doing
things that other people assign a high
level of fear to or a high level of risk
to you know like I'm literally drawn to
those things I think I think naturally I
think it led to some bad behaviors when
I was younger I was drawn to stuff that
was like risky but in a bad way but then
as I kind of course corrected my life I
I began gravitating towards these
challenges and things that like were
terrifying or or carried a high amount
of risk with them but I just wanted to
do them but like in my brain It's a
combination of I don't want to [__]
do this at all and that's why I want to
do it and so I'm totally torn at all
times and then as soon as I do it like I
have to find a new thing to do that's
also scary and so that's that's just
that's how I'm wired uh and I've been
able to harness it to help grow you know
my end of the business um and I'm
preaching it like like crazy to my kids
like we go water parks are a big thing
that's our our vacation our water parks
and my oldest is like obsessed with
slides like water slides is always on
YouTube like watching different slides
like in Dubai or whatever but then we
get to the parks and she's like super
nervous about all the slides you know
she she like she seems really confident
get and she doesn't want to do it and
I'm like you got to do things that scare
you buddy you got you got to do it and
she'll like say it to herself she like
yeah I got to do things that scare me
and she'll do the slide and it's like at
the end she's like glowing she's like I
can't believe I did that and so it's
like rubbing off on her you know I think
public speaking is like the most common
fear people are like I'd rather die than
speak in public you know it's like yeah
yeah it's yeah I'm I'm not a public
speaker I am in a studio by myself
speaker but are you going to do great oh
thank you I heard a quote that was
turned nervousness and anxiety into
excitement because they're very close
emotions but excitement just has like
this positive over and undertone true I
think that like I think it was like
Michael Phelps maybe was it him that
said it I think so because someone asked
him how are you able to stay So Cal
given like the stakes of what you're
doing and he's like well I just yeah
nervousness and excitement are kind of
the same emotion and my coach tells me
to just like turn your nerves into
excitement and that's what I do and it's
like really so it's that simple but it's
like that's why you're a world class
Olympic Athlete because you can do that
not everyone can do that you know so I
don't think I can do that I think I I
ride the fear train doing it I just do
it anyways yeah Ballin management is
that something you'd like to talk about
yeah I touched on it briefly yeah we we
have a couple of creators that were
managing that Nick uh built out Ballin
management the analogy I give uh I've
given to Nick and he's used this it's
like if if you're playing if I use B B
I'm a big baseball fan by the way oh
cool me too yeah huge baseball fan uh so
if you're a really good baseball player
and and you can go pro you want to go
pro you want you want to play for like
you know whatever your best team is like
for me the Red Sox like if I if I'm like
the best collegiate baseball player like
I'm not going to be like I'm going to go
to like you know some random country and
go play baseball there no you're going
to go to like the show you're going to
go to like major league baseball that's
where you want to be and so we want ball
and Studios to become the equivalent of
like the Boston Red Sox but for
storytellers like the the place you want
to go if you're a Storyteller and you
want to like expand and be the most
noteworthy and have the most resources
and the most reach you go to Ballin
Studios and they get access to your like
37p like like assistance on script
writing and like edting is an enormous
amount of support that is both current
and being built I mean Nick is very
aggressive about hiring early and like
establishing different ETS of people
that are ready to support these new
people when they come in so that when
they arrive it's not like don't worry
we're going to help you it's like here's
all your brand deals that that Nick
already got for you here's the people
that are going to help you write
research edit like what else do you need
like we'll pay for it you know left and
so we want it to be like you've made it
if you're a Storyteller we're at the
early stages of that but like that's we
have a very high threshold of quality
for everything we're doing which is why
we have super intense hiring processes
and boot camps you got to go through
because we really want this to be like
the creme de La Creme of like
professional storytelling also in order
to really grow up we need other hosts I
cannot do all the different shows and so
we need like an army of hosts you know
what you need honestly I think a kids
channel where you tell uh fun stories
for kids definitely is is one for sure
and I think that that's it's a delicate
area because one of the things we've
been told by people we've spoken to is
like once you go kid once you go Ju it's
very difficult to like keep the brand
relevant for adults that it almost
taints the brand for adults even even
like a separate Channel separate person
part of the ecosystem I would be nervous
about a little bit of cross
contamination yeah I mean it's one of
those things that we've kind of like put
on the back burner but not like we'll
never do that more like okay we'll keep
it 18 plus at least in theory one of the
things that it is is uh so we have
what's called uh aspirational is that
the demographic where like even though
the content is absolutely Ely designed
for adults we're not I'm not telling
these stories for kids they're for
adults but undoubtedly kids are watching
this content and there's like there's I
don't know like coolness to you're watch
you watch an R-rated movie when you're
not 17 like I've done that you know what
I mean and so I think that we're
actually already
capturing a slightly juvenile audience
not kids kids but like you know
teenagers and stuff um if we ever get
into like true kids content I think it
would just be a very deliberate move
that would be very mapped out you know
okay well so yeah so we have a new show
that's coming out next week uh it's the
first co-production we're doing with
Amazon music so through Wonder Studios
so our our studio has a a deal with
Amazon music uh and so we're doing
medical Mysteries uh it's gonna it's
very it'll sound like uh all of the
shows that I do right now on YouTube or
podcast but it'll be themed around
medical Mysteries I think I actually you
already did one that was a medical video
I've seen like Bas we touched some
medical stories on YouTube you and there
was one that was like really confusing I
forget it like got into her lungs or
something Gloria Ramirez yes yes that
one was really fascinating that one like
had my brain I like looked up the thing
and all that stuff like afterwards yeah
no that yeah so she she went in feeling
sick she had she was like a terminal
cancer and she was doing DIY treatments
which included rubbing this wax it was
like a mechanical wax or something you
can pick up at the hardware store like
all over her body which apparently
people had said that worked for this
type of cancer and so she was doing that
but then her her her organs started to
shut down she got brought into the
emergency room and she began emitting
this odor this like garlicky odor and
like the nurses and doctors began
passing out in the room with her uh they
tried to take her blood but when they
pulled the blood out it like
crystallized inside of the the tube it
like Turned these white crystals and
then uh basically turned into this like
biohazard this gas coming off of her
body and from the blood samples the
short version is uh it was this perfect
series of events that I don't explicitly
remember but it started with this wax
she put on her skin absorbed it and then
it mixed with the type of treatment she
was getting for her cancer I believe and
it created this like new chemical that
is harmless unless it's like oxidized or
something and like the first step that
the the doctors took when they brought
her in was to like give her oxygen you
know because it was just like yeah it
was when she was taking the oxygen it
continually got worse so like the oxygen
mixed with the new chemical and created
a toxic chemical but don't worry it's
only toxic if it gets pulled out of her
body and they began tulling her her
blood out and they crystallized and that
was the the new compound but don't worry
it's in the vial still it's okay but
they were like what are these crystals
they put them on Petri dishes and
suddenly you've exposed this chemical to
the open air and it became lethal that's
insane so she ended up passing away I
probably got some details wrong there
but that's the gist of the story it was
like all the things that happened in a
row had to happen exactly as they
happened any of the steps that were
taken by the doctors at the times they
took them there would have been no issue
no one would have gotten no one would
have passed out no odor nothing it was
like every little thing had to be
exactly right like the odds of this
happening are basically zero wow so yeah
medical if you're into that stuff
medical M loves that episode Graham's
probably anxious cuz he's got a flight
he's got to catch boards in less than an
hour oh God you got go I just want to
say thank you so much this has been
honor I love your channel I love it so
much thank you very and then I'm
supposed to remind Jack to oh yes okay
get the thumbnail real quick let me get
a thumbnail
[Music]
yeah leave it rolling real quick okay so
so serious just
leave